Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka W.
Monka W.
Monka W
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
So, da bin ich.
Ex...
Gator Sound. Ja.
Oh, das muss ich wieder ausschalten.
Chatke, das Sponsoring ist vorbei.
Moment, aber den Link gibt es immer noch.
Aber das Sponsoring ist vorbei.
Seit vorgestern.
Moment.
Egal, das mache ich nach dem Stream aus.
Dass es alle halbe Stunde mal was spammt,
das ist, glaube ich, schon okay.
Ah, sehr entspannte Musik.
Oh, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat. Ganz wichtig.
Sekunde. Sekunde. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich muss mir unbedingt was zu trinken holen.
Ich habe gar nichts da. Weder Tee, noch Wasser, noch sonst was.
Wenn ich jetzt hier ein paar Stunden am Start bin und ich nichts zu trinken habe,
dann kriege ich einen trockenen Hals und das ist nichts.
Ne, ne, gleich wieder am Start.
Musik
Vertraue und glaube, es hilft, es heilt die göttliche Kraft!
Jetzt aber.
Keine Ahnung, ob das viel ist.
Müsste man vergleichen auf Guides halt oder so.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, es kostet halt aktuell gerade einfach so viel.
Speicher ist halt saumäßig teuer.
Leute, ich bin heute schon 11 Kilometer gerannt.
Um genau zu sein, ich muss mal kurz reingucken,
dass meine Garmin-App sagt.
Ja.
11,01 Kilometer.
6,33 pro Kilometer.
Also relativ langsam.
Dafür auch nur 147 durchschnittlicher Puls.
Und er ist schon ein bisschen höher, weil es so warm ist.
Ich merke das jedes Mal.
Es ist viel anstrengender.
Eine Stunde zwölf.
Und angeblich habe ich 932 Kalorien verbraucht.
Selbst wenn es nur 700 oder so sind, ist das immer noch nice.
Für dich.
So, gut, jetzt bin ich ready.
Alles klar, schalten wir mal den Linux-Mini-PC ein.
Ja, ja.
OBS.
Und loggen uns mal bei Set-Servers ein.
Ansonsten muss ich euch noch was Lustiges von der Arbeit erzählen.
Ich mach jetzt hier erstmal an.
Zack.
Tastatur umstöpseln.
Muss ich euch was Lustiges von der Arbeit erzählen.
Und zwar, das ist so, ich bin ja da gezwungen, ein Windows-Notebook zu verwenden.
Das habe ich euch ja glaube ich schon, ich habe da sogar mal ein eigenes Video zu gemacht,
wie vollgekleistert das mit irgendwelchen, in Anführungszeichen, Security-Sachen ist.
Ich bin ja gezwungen, ein Windows-Notebook zu verwenden.
Ich benutze das im Endeffekt auch nur, um mir eine Konsole Fullscreen aufzumachen,
per X-Forwarding und dann alles auf meine Linux-Kiste.
Aber gut, also letztendlich unter der Haube ist das ein Windows-Notebook.
und
also ist das nicht so als
will ich das, ne, ich sag nur
ich hab da gar keinen Bock drauf, aber es ist so
so
und
ab und zu
ist das dann so, wenn du dich
einstöpselst in der
also an der
Dockingstation, wenn du dich einstöpselst
dann
kriegst du automatisch
Security Updates
wenn du auf der Arbeit bist.
So, und ich hatte am
Freitag, also gestern,
lief so ein
Security-Update oder generell
Security-Update, stimmt nicht.
Das updatete alles möglich. Lief so ein komischer
Update-Paket-
Aktualisierungslauf.
Und danach ging
mein Zytrix nicht mehr.
Weil ich mach das ja so, ich benutze ja eigentlich
nur noch das Zytrix zum Einloggen.
Dann habe ich da habe ich dann alles drauf und da dann im Fullscreen eine Konsole. Also es ist quasi Remote in Remote, wenn du so willst. Ist ein bisschen laggy, aber immer noch besser als Windows zu verwenden.
zumindest irgendwie ist bei dem Update die Zytrix-Installation kaputt gegangen.
Nachdem das ja eine Windows-Kiste ist, hatte ich keine Möglichkeit, dass...
Also eine quasi... Wie nennt man das?
Managed Windows-Kiste ist.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das im Windows-Umfeld nennt.
Ich kann da drauf nichts machen. Ich habe da keine Admin-Rechner,
so einen ganz normalen Client-Rechner.
Ich habe zwar Hut auf allen Produktions-Linux-Kisten
und könnte da Millionen Schaden verursachen,
wenn ich es wirklich drauf anlegen will.
Aber bei Notebook kriege ich natürlich keine Root-Rechte.
Logisch, wer weiß, was so der Linux-Admin mit seinem Windows anstellt.
Wenn ich roote auf meiner Windows-Kiste,
würde ich mir eine VL mit Linux installieren.
Naja, zumindest ging das Zytrix nicht mehr,
was ich gebraucht habe zum Arbeiten.
Ich habe ja sonst nichts.
Ich habe Zytrix-Kiste, auf die ich mich einloggen kann
und
Nutzt ihr admin VDIs?
Nee
Also wir können wir können also wir können uns eine admin windows kiste beantragen eine virtuelle admin kiste
Wo wir admin recht drauf haben können wir uns beantragen habe ich aber nicht ich habe eine ganz normale windows
zittricks kiste also ganz normales windows notebook mit zittricks und die
also das benutze ich dann quasi mich da einzuloggen so und dann mache ich
terminal im fullscreen auf und dann war es das stein er hat ein angeschöpftes
ab zumindest das zittricks hat nicht mehr funktioniert nach dem update wir
haben so eine hotline habe ich bei der hotline angerufen habe gesagt hier
leute ich kann nicht mehr arbeiten mein zittricks geht nicht mehr kann man nicht
auf meine kiste die sprache zum arbeiten verbinden
da hat der Hotline-Mensch, da hat es ja wirklich Mühe gegeben, muss man sagen, rumgeguckt und hat keine Lösung gefunden.
Und dann hat er das weitergeleitet irgendwie ans Zytrix-Team oder whatever.
Zumindest hat eine ganze Weile gedauert.
Also ich wurde im Endeffekt versucht, ich glaube zwei, drei Stunden oder so hat das, ich glaube knapp drei Stunden hat das sogar gedauert.
Also ich wurde im Endeffekt am Freitag für drei Stunden Reddit-Scrollen bezahlt.
Weil ich konnte nichts machen.
Windows-Updates haben mich arbeitsunfähig gemacht.
Habe ich halt drei Stunden Reddit geguckt und ein bisschen Zeiterfassung gemacht.
So ein paar sinnvolle Sachen habe ich schon gemacht.
Ich habe alte Tickets noch geschlossen und Zeiterfassung gemacht.
Aber ansonsten habe ich alle zwei Stunden Reddit gescrollt, bis der Kram wieder funktioniert hat.
Zumindest der Witz, warum ich euch das Ganze erzähle, ist folgendes.
Wisst ihr, was die Lösung war meines Zytrix-Problems?
Das ist wirklich ein absoluter Classic Windows Admin-Stelz.
Die haben mir eine Mail geschrieben.
Sehr geehrter Herr Max, wir haben gesehen, Sie haben ganz viele Updates installiert.
Und man muss dazu sagen, ich habe extra, nachdem ich neu gestartet habe,
dieses Update-Installierprogramm nochmal neu gestartet.
Da stand, es gibt keine neuen Updates.
So anscheinend hat sich das irgendwie serverseitig verknotet.
Und mir wurden keine neuen Updates mehr angezeigt oder keine Updates.
So, und das haben die dann irgendwie angeklickt auf Serverseite und dann haben die mir geschrieben,
sehr geehrter Herr Max, starten Sie, also ich kann es nicht wortwörtlich wiedergeben,
aber sinngemäß stand da drin, starten Sie Ihren Notebook neu, führen Sie die Softwareverwaltung aus,
dann starten Sie nochmal neu und führen die Softwareverwaltung nochmal aus
und das Ganze dann am besten nochmal
oder am besten zweimal.
Das war die Lösung.
Ich soll mein fucking Notebook dreimal neu starten,
dann geht's wieder.
Also mehr Classic Windows geht ja wohl kaum.
Dreimal, dreimal neu starten.
Omega Lul.
ReStore.
Oh ne, gehen wir bloß fort.
Microsoft Zeug kann ich euch nicht geben.
Zack.
Terminal.
Zedke.
Ach ne, Moment.
Ah, ich muss mich ja wieder neu einloggen.
Ja.
Das mache ich gleich.
Da dürft ihr nicht hingucken.
top secret login
liegt er jetzt so nix liegt jetzt noch nicht aber wir machen jetzt erstmal die
Updates. Und dann machen wir
Reboot.
Was macht
die Jetbrains Dinger?
Ah, die haben wir das letzte Mal alle geupdatet.
Oh, was ist denn das?
Was ist er? Das kenne ich noch nicht.
Ein Agentic. Oh Gott.
Please, no. No.
Lasst mich in Ruhe.
Das Jetbrains AI-Zeug ist schon so schlecht.
No, God.
Please, no. No.
No.
lange wachs für den zap das ohne scheiß die die die ki integration bei den chat
mit sagen die ist so schlecht da wollen übrigens auch noch geld dafür haben die
ist so schlecht und jetzt haben wir noch ein eigenes agentic development
environment also quasi eine keine idee sondern eine ade sonst etwas neues ich
bin noch nie aufgefallen ist das neu haben die das erst letzten segen wie
vorgestellt oder so. Habe ich noch nie hier drinnen
gesehen.
Ich finde es auch ein bisschen blöd, dass
das so ein komisches Logo hat und
keins von ihren normalen
Logos.
Guck, weil die normalen
IDEs haben ja diese Logos hier.
Er. Gab es nicht mal
gab es nicht mal, er?
Gab es nicht mal so ein Ding?
Quasi so
eine Art Flash?
So
Offline Flash oder irgendwie sowas
Gab doch mal sowas, oder?
Adobe Air gab es doch mal irgendwann
Ich glaube Plants vs. Zombies
Das originale Plants vs. Zombies 1
War glaube ich in Adobe Air
Programmiert damals
Yes, installieren
Traue ich mich, Leute
Trau ich mich?
Ne.
Ich mach keine Art User-Repo-Updates mehr.
Denied.
Aber jetzt muss ich erstmal Package-Updates machen.
Chat, ich bin ja froh, dass mich noch keiner zum Thema Chat-Kontrolle gefragt hat.
Das wäre mir auch ganz lieb, wenn wir das
lassen könnten heute, weil dann rege ich mich
nur auf.
Dann rege ich mich ja lieber über C++ auf,
als über den Scheiß, Alter.
Wilder Egel, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Elektron42.
Moment, warum muss das
explizit 42 sein?
Seit gestern Abend, ne seit einer Woche
Keine Updates mehr gemacht
Hast du mal in den Black Ops 1
2 PS5-Bot geschaut?
Das Problem ist
Ich seh nicht ein, mir Black Ops 1
Und 2 nochmal neu zu kaufen
Und zweitens hab ich keine PS5
Insofern
Fällt das aus mehreren Gründen flach
Ich habe gelesen, dass die Probleme haben mit den Lobbys.
Und dass es wohl irgendwie Input-Lag gibt, wenn man bestimmte Settings für den Controller nicht ändert.
Habe ich heute irgendwo gelesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es auf Twitter war oder auf Reddit.
Wahrscheinlich auf Reddit.
Ich wollte jetzt mal gucken, warum ist es Elektron 42?
Warum ist es nicht einfach nur Elektron?
Ist es irgendeine feste Version?
Okay, vielleicht ist es 42 Stable Version.
Reboot
Recommended, Leute
Dann machen wir das doch mal
Reboot
Oh, wenn man es jetzt so richtig schreibt
Oh, Chat
So viele Erste nicht supported
Maximale Anzahl an Ersten sind so
Das geht aber nicht
Also das sind nicht
da sind nicht genug erst. Sekunde, das muss ich
anpassen.
Äh. Wo hab ich denn meine
Funktion, die das... Hier, 200.
200 muss das
sein. So, jetzt müssen wir
mal gucken.
Ja.
Guck mal hier.
So viele
Reboot-Möglichkeiten, wie wir hier haben.
Es braucht schon zwei Zeilen, so viel
Reboot.
Wenn jetzt einer
ein stream kommt der fragt sich auch was zum teufel geht ja okay wir machen jetzt
hier ein reboot einen ganz besonders reboot durch ein reboot
bam
listening reiseentspannende musik
Reboot.
So, Tastatur wieder anstöpseln.
Ich könnte ja auch das Ganze per SSH machen, ne?
Das hatten wir doch schon mal.
Dass man das per SSH anlocken kann.
Aber dann bräuchte ich eine Kiste, von der ich SSHen kann.
Ey, ich stöpsel kurz die...
Stöpsel kurz die Tastatur an.
Das dauert zwei Sekunden oder so.
Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht vertippt habe, sollte der eigentlich booten.
Boot Champ.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich auf KDE bleibe.
Ja, Leute, das hier.
Beste.
Früher konnte man ja noch Compets verwenden für sowas, aber Compets in der Form ist ja outdated, overrated, she baited und bei Wayland geht's eh nicht mehr.
Ja, noch passiert ja nix.
Noch passiert nix.
Aber, aber, hier ist mal ne Frage.
Oh, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Chatterino.
Frage an dich, Samu.
Samu.
Wenn es dir hier nichts sagt, wie findest du als vielleicht nicht ganz so tief in dieser Materie drinnen steckende, wie findest du den Wobbly-Windows-Effekt?
Das müsste es überall geben, oder? Ist das nicht geil? Dass die Fenster so wobbeln?
Ich finde, das ist das Beste. Eigentlich müsste das überall supportet werden.
Leider gibt es das nicht für Windows und gibt es das nicht für Mac. Aber Wobbly-Windows ist schon das Geilste, was es gibt.
Guck mal, nochmal, weißt du, was noch besser ist?
Guck mal, siehst du, wie das wobbelt, wenn ich Fullscreen und Unfullscreen mache?
Guck mal, wie das so rein wobbelt, so reinfaded, ey.
So, was soll man machen?
Wobbel, wobbel, wobbel und dann hier, guck mal, wuuuh.
Menschen, denen übel wird, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Das ist ja nicht VR-Wobbly-Windows.
Das ist...
Wisst ihr, dass das 240
240 Hertz Wobbly Windows ist?
Das sind 240
240 Hertz Wobbly Windows.
Ihr seht das, ihr seht, bei euch ruckelt das
tatsächlich ein bisschen, weil ihr seht das nur mit
48 FPS.
Aber das hier selbst läuft mit 240 FPS.
Ne, ihr seht das, ihr seht das nicht.
Ich stream nur mit 48 FPS.
100 prozent cpu usage wollen mal gucken ob das stimmt
wir gucken mal wie viel wie viel gpu use wie viel gpu usage durch wobbly windows zustande kommt
soll ich jetzt mal hier ganz viele windows
Super, gewobbel.
Okay, und wie viel...
Naja.
Also wir sind mal ganz kurz bei sehr viel
Gewobbel auf 50% GPU-Auslastung.
Ich kotz gleich.
Tja, das ist Risiko.
Also 50%.
Wir sind ganz kurz auf 50%
GPU-Auslastung gekommen, nur durch das Wobbeln
von Windows.
Aber das ist auch keine geile CPU, ne?
Das ist...
Das ist nur eine
AMD Radeon 780M.
Ja, ja, das ist schon wert.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich auf KDE bleibe, weil Wobbly Windows beste.
T... Warum...
Warum ist da Temu am Start?
Kann sich das mal verpissen vielleicht.
Deutscher Otto Lahn, auch weg.
Alternate darf da bleiben, die haben mich gesponsert.
Alles, was mich gesponsert hat, darf prinzipiell da bleiben.
Oh, es ist 30 Grad.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass es 30 Grad ist.
Ich war vorhin draußen, es war richtig heiß.
War bestimmt 35 Grad oder so.
Was interessiert mich?
Das Wetterbericht hier im Browser.
Ich sitze in klimatisierten
Klimaanlagen mit der Klimaanlage
hier im Büro.
Oh, das ist eine gut.
WubWijen.
Das finde ich
eine gute Idee.
Also, aber das muss ich echt demnächst mal beauftragen.
Wupp, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Dann irgendwas mit einer Spritze drauf oder so.
Aber Wupp, Wupp, Vegan ist auch...
Also, bevor jetzt einer kommt, ich bin nicht vegan.
Ich lebe nicht vegan.
Ich mach das nur aus gesundheitlichen Gründen, dass ich mich versuche, ein bisschen weniger Fleisch zu futtern.
Und da habe ich jetzt halt so vegane Ersatzdinger für mich entdeckt.
Also ich habe die letzten Wochen so gut wie kein Fleisch mehr gefuttert.
Das hat aber gar nicht primär irgendwie was mit dem Tierwohl zu tun, sondern das ist ganz eigennützig.
Das ist, weil ich mal irgendwo vor einer Weile so eine Studie drüber gesehen habe,
wie ungesund das eigentlich ist, wenn man jeden Tag massig Fleisch futtert.
So für Darmkrebs und was es sich da alles gibt.
Deswegen wollte ich das nicht mehr machen.
Und seitdem futter ich so ein bisschen veganes Zeug, auch auf der Arbeit, in der Kantine.
Aber ich bin kein Veganer.
Ich futter durchaus ab und zu noch Schnitzel und sowas.
Nächstes Jahr wählst du die Grün.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich wählen soll.
Ich hab wirklich gar keinen blassen Schimmer.
Nachdem wir immer so richtig krass gefickt wurden mit der Chat-Kontrolle.
Aber da will ich mich gar nicht drüber auflassen.
Ich wollte dazu gar nichts sagen, sonst reg ich mich nur wieder auf.
Ich reg mich schnell doof.
So, dann loggen wir uns doch mal.
Max hat's Tränen.
Sehr gute Idee.
Das stimmt.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich unterm Strich immer noch gesünder, als jeden Tag massig Fleisch zu futtern.
Ich brauche keine Ergänzungsmittel.
Ich futter so viel Zeug.
und nur weil ich
teilweise Fleisch
durch vegane Produkte ersetzt habe,
heißt das ja nicht, dass ich gar kein Fleisch mehr futte.
Ich futte jetzt im empfohlenen
Rahmen Fleisch, ja,
anstatt zu viel.
Du meinst, wir können den Titel noch länger machen?
Blutwerte sind bei mir übrigens alle
exzellent.
Ja, ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich hab da kein Problem.
Ich futter noch genug Zeug.
Genau.
Ich mach das eigentlich nur, dass ich nicht
in den quasi nicht empfohlenen
Bereich von Fleischkonsum komme.
beispielsweise habe ich letzte woche in der kantine oft an der salattheke gab es
wurscht salat da habe ich mir auch eine kelle rein gehauen also ich glaube nicht
dass ich da liegen der form mangel zeug habe aber irgendwann demnächst lasse ich
mir immer wieder blut abnehmen so dann aber nicht wenn man nicht neuerungen
dort nicht elf das wollten wir uns auch mal angucken aber jetzt nicht jetzt
machen wir mal hier auf firefox new private windows servers aber das andere
window aber immer noch wieder mal zu hier so login chat ihr müsst kurz weg gucken ich helfe
euch dabei beim weg gucken ich weiß es würde ja es würde ja von euch auch so keiner gucken richtig
wenn ich sag weg gucken natürlich alle weg aber ich helfe euch mal natürlich natürlich troste ich
im chat da komplett wenn die sagen wenn ihr sagt ihr guckt weg dann glaube ich euch das natürlich
auch.
Außer dem Chainlaw. Dem glaube ich das nicht.
Ihr habt die Login...
Oh nein, jetzt habe ich mich auch noch vertippt.
Ihr müsst noch ein bisschen länger
weggucken.
Ah, ich weiß, wo ich mich vertippt habe.
Okay.
Jetzt sind wir eingeloggt.
Exzellent.
So, jetzt dürft ihr wieder hingucken.
Ah, denke ich auch.
Es war einfach ungesund.
Ja, habe ich.
Übrigens, soll ich euch mal was richtig geiles erzählen?
Was die meisten von euch wahrscheinlich nicht geil finden, aber für Leute, die mit Google Cloud arbeiten vielleicht.
Was richtig, richtig nice ist.
Was Google überhaupt nicht in ihrer Hilfe drin stehen hat und überhaupt nicht promotet.
Übrigens, ich wurde, ich wurde, ich wurde hart jebaited von Google.
Äh, Health Check.
Fixed Port.
Moment, ich muss euch das mal kurz, äh, zeigen, wo mich Google hardcore jebaited hat.
Use Fixed Port.
Hier hat mich Google hardcore
gebetet.
Guck mal, ich wollte...
Gibt es da kein Beispiel für?
Ich brauche das Beispiel, was ich letztens gefunden habe.
Da hat mich Google
so krass verarscht.
Okay, man findet
mal wieder nichts.
Ja.
Also.
Hier steht eindeutig,
es ist egal, was das ist, ne?
Ich hab mir die Google Hilfe angeguckt.
Für... Das ist
ein Health Check. Ach, hier steht's ja
Enable, genau. Also, man kann,
wenn man einen Loadbalancer bei Google verwendet,
kann man dem einen Custom Health Check
einstellen, woran er halt checkt, ob das Backend,
auf das er Loadbalancen, also welches von den Backends,
auf das er Loadbalancen will,
Loadbalancen soll, gerade ready ist,
und welches nicht. Also wenn man da was runterfährt,
dann soll er natürlich nicht an den kaputten Server
Loadbalancen. So.
Und irgendwie hat der Health Check
ums Verrecken nicht funktioniert.
Und dann dachte ich mir so,
lass doch mal Logging einschalten,
dass ich sehe, was der Health Check
für Fehler ausgibt, wenn er
wenn er fehlschlägt.
Und da habe ich das eingetragen,
hier alles.
Also das ist JSON. Das Ganze gibt es auch
als YAML. Ich habe das als YAML
im Kubernetes-Config eingetragen.
Und hier unten steht eindeutig,
Leute, eindeutig steht
hier, LogConfig
Enable.
Ihr seid mein Zeuge, Leute.
So, und da habe ich
natürlich gesagt, hier, blub.yaml,
habe ich halt gesagt, in der Lateinan
LogConfig
Enable
Wie ist es in YAML so?
So, ne?
Darf man es auch klein schreiben?
So, das habe ich halt in meine
Config eingetragen. Ihr seht, hier steht es
Original so drin. LogConfig
Enable und dann True oder False.
Habe ich so eingetragen,
hat das Ding immer gesagt, nein, Syntax
falsch, nein, Syntax falsch, nein, Syntax
falsch.
So, stellt es sich raus,
Google hat hier Mist geschrieben.
Es ist nicht Enable,
sondern Enabled.
Ich hab da bestimmt eine Stunde rumprobiert,
bis ich gecheckt hab.
Oh, du holt mir, dankeschön für den Sub.
Enabled, Alter.
WTF?
Und ich hab's dann rausgekriegt
mit
CubeCTL Explain.
Ja, CubeCTL
Explain, das ist eine sehr nice
Geschichte
Man sieht sowas öfters, ja
Da kann man sich, guck da kannst du
Zum Beispiel, äh, da kannst du Ressourcen
Äh, explain, äh, na gut
Das ist jetzt blöd, ähm, da kannst du zum Beispiel
Sagen hier, explain health checks
Und dann sagt er dir, welche Felder
Es gibt und welche erlaubt, also das ist
Mega praktisch, CubeCTL explain
Ja, so haben wir es zumindest rausgekriegt
So, aber das ist gar nicht das, was ich euch erzählen wollte.
Ich wollte euch irgendwas anderes erzählen.
Was habe ich denn gesagt?
Was mega nice ist...
Ah ja, genau, was mega nice ist für alle, die Google Cloud verwenden.
Wusstet ihr mittlerweile?
Also, wenn ihr jetzt mal...
Wenn ihr googelt danach, ja?
Hier, Google Cloud Managed Prometheus Grafana.
Leute, diese Doku ist so hart.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die gevibe-coded ist oder so.
Aber die ist so wirr geschrieben und auch so ultra kompliziert.
Du musst ein Grafana im Cluster betreiben.
Guck hier, deploy, kubectl.
Und dann sollst du eine Data Source einrichten.
Und dass die Data Source dann funktioniert, musst du doch irgendwie automatisch Credentials synchen und sowas.
Ey, es ist so abartig kompliziert gemacht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum die das so beschreiben.
In Wirklichkeit, mittlerweile, das schreiben die bei Google bloß nicht.
Ist das total einfach.
Das ist total einfach.
Es gibt Grafana, sogar in der Free Grafana Version.
Grafana.
Google Cloud Monitoring Data Source.
Und das Einzige, was du da machen musst, ist...
Na gut, vielleicht finde ich ein paar Bilder dazu.
zumindest das einzige was du machen musst in der in der google cloud graf anna google cloud
monitoring data source du nimmst dir ein service account in der cloud generiert für den geheimes
quasi in den api kriegst du den graf anna ein und es funktioniert alles dieses ganze zeug was google
geschrieben hat brauchst du nicht du brauchst einfach irgendwo irgendein graf anna mit diesem
Plugin, was an die Google
Cloud APIs kommt, du generierst
einen API-Token für irgendeinen User, der
Matrix-Read-Rechte
hat und instant geht.
Du kannst auch alle
Managed Prometheus-Metriken und so abfragen,
überhaupt kein Problem. Das ist easy as fuck
mittlerweile. Keine Ahnung, was Google da für
Sachen schreibt. Also Leute, wenn
ihr Google Cloud verwendet, wenn ihr da
vielleicht auch das Managed
Prometheus von denen
verwendet zum Metriken-Collecten und
keinen Bock auf diese ekligen, hässlichen
Google Cloud Dashboards habt,
haut euch irgendwo einen Grafana hin,
Free-Version, tut's ohne
Probleme, connectet das mit
einem API-Key zu einem
Cloud-User, der halt nur API-Read-Rechte hat.
Ihr könnt's auch mit eurem Account
machen, ja? Das ist egal. Und dann
Bäm! Könnt ihr euch
Dashboards erstellen mit allen Metriken, die es gibt
in der Cloud und vor allem auch mit euren
Custom-Metriken. Das ist halt das
Gute. Wir haben halt relativ viele Custom-Metriken
mittlerweile
am Start, die auch über
Prometheus collected werden.
Und das haben wir alles jetzt bei uns im
Grafana drin, dadurch.
Also das war viel, viel, viel einfacher als gedacht.
Also für alle, die Google Cloud
Stills benutzen.
Ich glaube,
dass das bei Google und bei Microsoft
und wahrscheinlich bei Amazon auch
gar nicht mehr wirklich
echte Writer sind, die diese Dokumente
erstellen. Ich glaube, mittlerweile
werden diese Dinger komplett vibe-coated,
die Doc-Seiten.
Zumindest wirkt das oft so.
Ja, die haben bestimmt einen super advanceden
Prompt dafür,
aber das ist teilweise so...
So, weiß ich nicht, so...
So verbose einfach, ja?
Ein anderes Wort fällt mir dafür nicht ein.
Oder verbose, wie man es, glaube ich, richtig ausspricht.
Ja, die schreiben nicht.
die wisst ihr in den doku steht nicht drin
ähm
setze enabled
auf 1 oder setze enabled
auf true da steht erstmal
3 seiten drin wie du dein cubectl einrichtest
und gcloud auth machst und sowas
ähm
also die
seiten sind wirklich von arsch
und da kommen mal auch so sachen raus wie
Enable und Enabled und sowas.
Neuerung in .NET 11.
Ne, das gucken wir uns nächstes Mal an.
Das gucken wir uns nächstes Mal an.
Und wir gucken uns das vor allem,
gucken wir uns das nicht auf Deutsch an.
Und ich bin immer zu dumm.
Unten haben die das bei Microsoft, oder?
Deutsch hier.
Das ist einfach komplett hängen geblieben.
Gibt es nicht einfach ganz normales Englisch, Leute?
Gibt es United Kingdom?
United States. Okay.
Ich fände es übrigens
auch fail,
komplett userunfreundlich,
dass die
verbreiteten Sprachen
einfach nicht oben als Shortcut
stehen. Also zumindest mal Englisch.
Zumindest mal Englisch sollte direkt oben
stehen, dass es einfach nur anklicken muss.
Genau.
So, aber das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Wir fixen jetzt ein paar Linux-Server, Leute.
Was haben wir...
Achso, okay, die einfachen haben wir alle gemacht.
Letztes Mal haben wir ganz viel von den mittleren gemacht.
Ein paar schwere.
Das hatten wir auch schon gefixt.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben es nicht schnell genug abgeschlossen.
Mal gucken, was wir haben.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich...
Chat, ihr habt doch besser aufgepasst als ich.
Habe ich jetzt... Ja, ich habe rebooted, ne?
Backseating erlaubt.
Ja, im Rahmen.
Also ihr dürft alle mit... Also es ist erlaubt.
Ihr dürft alle mitraten, was jetzt Sache ist und so.
Wo ich keinen Bock drauf habe, ist, wenn die Leute anfangen,
Max, guck mal, ETC, blablabla, guck mal, was drauf hier in Celesa,
guck mal, welcher Port offen ist.
Das mache ich schon selbst.
Aber ihr dürft mitraten, was Sache ist.
So, jetzt muss ich mal was trinken.
Ups.
Fast mein Mikrofon ins Wasser gesteckt.
Oh, mir fällt gerade ein.
Ich muss ja...
Ich muss ja den Seagate und Ukraine Leuten...
...noch den Report schicken...
...für die Streams...
...für die Sellout-Streams...
damit ich meine Kohle kriege.
Gar nicht dran gedacht.
Sonst hätte ich ja
umsonst kostenloses Sellout gemacht.
Das wollen wir natürlich nicht.
Das wäre ja
Pepo Burn Money.
So, dann wollen wir mal.
Ich erkläre nochmal kurz, um was es geht, was das ist.
Alter, was ist jetzt mit der Musik los?
What the fuck?
WTF?
Okay, das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt sein.
Was ich übrigens auch richtig dämlich finde, dass Google sich nicht merkt, wo man aufgehört hat.
Okay, also ich werde nochmal kurz erklären, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Das ist im Endeffekt so was wie CTF für Linux Server, falls einem das was sagt.
Ansonsten werde ich jetzt einfach nochmal kurz erklären.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Es gibt hier...
Äh...
30...
68...
68 plus 19.
Quickmuffs.
Oh.
Was?
Gelobt sei der Herr täglich, Gott lege uns...
Was zum...
Wie kommt das jetzt auf irgendwelche Bibelferse?
Achso.
68, 19.
Okay.
Whatever.
Ich habe eigentlich drauf gehofft, 87.
87.
Pregge hier.
Pregge.
87.
Also hier gibt es 87 Szenarien.
In jedem Szenario bekommt man einen echten Linux-Server.
Das ist jetzt hier keine Sandbox-simulierte Umgebung, emulierte Umgebung oder so.
Also das ist wirklich eine echte Deluxe-Kiste, die man da bekommt.
Oder einen echten Kubernetes-Cluster, den man bekommt.
Und dazu gibt es, wir machen jetzt ganz schnell, einfach weil es am besten zu zeigen ist, nochmal Easy-Aufgabe 1 von 87.
Dann steht hier die Beschreibung, was es ist.
Developer created testing program und das testing program, das schreibt nach varlog bedlog.
und macht die Platte voll
und wir sollen jetzt gucken,
dass wir das Programm killen,
was eben in dieses Log schreibt.
Das ist die erste Aufgabe unter Easy,
die ist auch wirklich easy.
Wenn man jetzt auf Run drückt,
dann wird im Hintergrund eine AWS-VM hochgefahren.
Ich glaube, unter der Haube ist das halt
irgendeine Mischung aus Ansible und Terraform,
was der verwendet.
Also sprich, der professioniert jetzt im Hintergrund
bei AWS eine VM,
lässt einen Ansible-Job drauflaufen, der die VM quasi in den Zustand bringt, wie sie sein muss,
halt dass es eben der Aufgabe entspricht, der quasi die VM kaputt macht.
Und dann darf man sich auf die VM verbinden und muss den Fehler fixen.
Und wenn man den Fehler gefixt hat, gibt es einen Button, um das Ganze zu überprüfen, ob man es richtig gemacht hat.
Das dauert meistens so eine Minute, bis die VM da ist.
Und was mittlerweile richtig nice ist, also man kann zugreifen auf die VM über einen Browser,
Man kann mittlerweile aber auch, wenn man einen Public-SSH-Key hinterlegt,
SSH drauf zugreifen.
Was ich persönlich sehr angenehm finde,
weil man dann keine Links mehr leaken kann.
Sonst könnte ich vor allem aber langsamer ready werden.
So, hier, genau, zack.
Hier ist, nehmen wir mal hier, IP von dem Server.
ssh
Ich hoffe dann nimmt den richtigen key
Nimmt den richtigen key. Exzellent. Oh nein das ist auch keine leaked ip
Das ist irgendein proxy server der bei dem steht
so genau jetzt ist man auf dem server drauf hier das ist richtig wie ihr seht das ist eine
richtig echte linux kiste ja kann man auch top ausführen und sich das angucken man kann es
theoretisch wahrscheinlich weiß ich auch mal reboot kann hat man gut rechte also richtig echte
tucor 512 mb linux kiste
die bis ls genau und da müssen wir jetzt quasi den server reparieren indem wir das hier also
wir müssen das fixen was hier steht also dass das schreibt ihr das unter wahlok bett lockt
ein log file gibt wo ein programm reinschreibt das programm soll werden also mal alles auf
gucken uns das an.
Aha, wir sehen auf diese Datei
greift dieser Prozess zu und dann sagen wir
im Endeffekt kill, bam, dieser Prozess.
Gucken, beendet.
Also wie gesagt, das ist die erste Aufgabe, easy.
Warum sudo minus i und nicht
sudo minus u? Kannst beides machen.
Aber
sudo minus i führt
interaktive Login-Skripts aus.
Ich glaube, wenn schon, müsstest du sudo minus
su minus machen, dass es genau das gleiche
ist. So, zumindest wenn man
fertig ist und
checken will, ob man es richtig gemacht hat,
kann man hier auf Check my Solution drücken.
Wenn man nicht drauf kommt, hier steht übrigens auch,
wie viel Zeit man hat, das Ganze zu lösen.
Wenn man nicht drauf kommt,
wie man ein Problem beheben kann,
dann kann man sich hier auch noch
ein paar Tipps
anzeigen lassen, wie das
funktionieren könnte.
Und
hier am Ende sagt es einem dann auch, was man
machen muss, wenn man
gar zu viele Tipps braucht.
So, wenn man durch ist, sagt man Check my solution, bam, korrekt, dann wird die VM wieder runtergefahren.
Also das ist im Prinzip die Funktionsweise davon.
Häkchen heißt, haben wir schon gemacht.
Das hier ist keine Aufgabe, das ist irgendwas anderes, keine Ahnung.
Das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas für Vorstellungsgespräche oder sowas.
Weil das ist natürlich auch eine wirklich super...
Guck mal, das ist ganz neu.
Ah ne, das ging das letzte Mal nicht.
Deswegen ist das noch offen.
Das ging das letzte Mal nicht.
Ja.
Und das ist natürlich auch ein super Tool,
wenn man für Vorstellungsgespräche, ne.
Ich hab das versucht, meinem Chef schon schmackhaft zu machen.
Falls mir mal wieder Linux-Leute einstellen.
Der soll denen einfach mal ein paar Easy-Aufgaben geben.
Und wenn sich einer bei Easy-Aufgaben, also wenn jemand sagt, er hat Linux-Erfahrung, ja, und er tut sich bei Easy-Aufgaben schon schwer, dann hat er wahrscheinlich doch nicht so krass viel Linux-Erfahrung, wie gesagt.
Da können die Leute aber übrigens oftmals selbst gar nichts für.
Beim letzten Arbeitgeber hat sich bei uns einer beworben, der hat auch reingeschrieben, er hat schon jahrelange Erfahrung mit VMware, jahrelange Erfahrung mit Ubuntu Linux.
und am Ende hat sich rausgestellt, er hat mal vor ein paar Jahren Ubuntu Linux auf VMware Workstation installiert.
Und er war ganz verwirrt, warum wir ihn so viel nach Linux gefragt haben.
Er hat das nämlich überhaupt nicht reingeschrieben.
Der Recruiter, der Recruiter hat dem seine Skill-Liste übelst frisiert.
Also der wusste gar nicht, dass er angeblich 5 Jahre plus Linux und VMware Erfahrung hatte.
Also doppelt G-Bated.
Wir wurden G-Bated und der Bewerber wurde auch G-Bated.
Der Recruiter hat uns beide G-Bated.
Ihr könnt euch jetzt aussuchen, was wir machen wollen.
Sagen wir mal, wir fangen mal mit noch ein paar mittleren Aufgaben an.
Ähm, keine Ahnung.
Ihr könnt euch... Okay, was wollen wir machen?
Zwischen 16 und 25 könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
Also wir haben Restore MySQL Database, Restore MySQL Database Spooked by a Ghost, Handshark Issue in Kubernetes, How much do you press? Keine Ahnung, was da dahinter steckt.
Prometheus kann irgendwelche Sachen nicht scrapen.
Security Snack.
Postgres Physical Replication
Supervisor Still Around
Engine X with Brodli
und XZ
LZMA
Security Snack
Also ich trinke
jetzt noch was, ich gebe euch noch mal 20 Sekunden Zeit,
falls einer noch was anderes sehen will,
könnt ihr in den Chat schreiben, ansonsten machen wir jetzt 21.
Komm, ich muss ja gleich noch neues Wasser holen.
Helmstadt 18.
Okay, dann machen wir erst 21.
Gut.
Dann machen wir 21 und danach machen wir 18.
Wenn ich es wieder vergessen habe, Leute, erinnert mich dran.
Wobei, ich kann es mir eigentlich schon aufmachen.
Das ist gut.
So.
Dann schauen wir doch mal.
Security Snack.
Also.
Description.
Mary und John.
Das erinnert mich.
Gibt es da nicht von Otto irgendwas?
Mary?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Doch irgendwas gab es da von Otto.
Okay, also Mary und John, die arbeiten an einer Golang-Applikation.
Und das Security-Team ist um die Ecke gekommen.
und hat gesagt, die sollen ein paar Security-Maßnahmen implementieren.
Das ist doch immer Kacke, oder? Was wollen die eigentlich?
Einfach alles public ohne Authentifizierung. Gut ist, kann doch nichts kaputt gehen.
Leider haben sie die Applikationen damit kaputt gemacht und die funktionieren nicht mehr.
Und jetzt müssen sie uns fragen, um Hilfe, das Ganze wieder zu fixen.
so fix application should be able to allow clients to communicate with the application over https
ok also https mit den clients dass das riecht mir nach ein bisschen zertifikats zeug kann das sein
Nein.
Das wird wieder eklig.
Ich hasse Zertifikatssachen.
By the way.
Was ist eigentlich mit meinem...
Guck mal, ich hab das in der Zwischenablage.
Aber hier steht nicht, dass ich es in der Zwischenablage hab.
Ist die Wayland-Zwischenablage kaputt?
Ich meine, es ist Wayland.
Und wenn ich das jetzt hier so kopiere, so, ist es dann im Clipboard Manager?
Ja, dann ist es im Clipboard Manager.
Okay.
Hm.
Naja, schauen wir mal.
Reroll auf eine frühere Version.
Ja, wenn es direkt an der Anwendung liegt, wäre das tatsächlich ein gangbarer Weg, ja.
Wenn man komplette Server-Snapshots hat, ist es natürlich noch nicer.
Aber dann sind ja wieder die Security-Measures nicht implementiert.
Müsste dann jemand anderes entscheiden, was man macht.
Aber wir gucken uns das Ganze jetzt erstmal an.
Also, Server-IP, zack.
Den nehmen wir.
SSH.
Admin.
Yes.
Und da sind wir drauf.
also dann führen wir doch immer den curl aus und mal gucken was der köln sagt also
köln muss ja angeblich kaputt sein code not resolved host web app
haben wir root rechte erstmal check haben wir root rechte wo liegt denn die go anwendung überhaupt
steht das da auch irgendwo
weiß nicht aber wahrscheinlich wir können nicht
Promptail, SSH,
DHCP-Client.
Also auf 7000
habe ich jetzt nichts gesehen.
Es wäre natürlich nicht verkehrt,
wenn man uns mitgeteilt hätte,
wo die Go-Anwendung liegt.
Na gut.
Vielleicht liegt die hier?
Im Heimatverzeichnis irgendwo?
Nö.
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Wo sie nicht da ist.
Habe ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen?
Wo die Anwendung liegt, die nicht geht?
Gucken wir mal,
ob jetzt hier Hauszengel was drin entsteht.
Auch nicht.
Moment, Leute, ich muss mal das hier auf den ersten Desktop verschieben.
Ich drücke nämlich immer eins.
So, habe ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen oder steht da nichts?
Ich meine, es ist relativ easy.
Wir können einfach mal in den Check gucken.
Da finden wir es raus.
Okay, also wir müssen auf jeden Fall Web-App auflösen können.
Okay, also heißt...
Irgendwo
Also wir brauchen wahrscheinlich
Ein Host
Ist das vielleicht Docker
Docker-Stills oder was
Ne
Ist es nicht
Okay, dann gucken wir einfach mal, ob wir irgendwas finden
Unter ETC
Irgendwas mit Port 7000
Okay
Das sieht schon, äh, nein
Ah.
Okay, ich sehe hier schon mal ein Problem.
Ich sehe hier schon mal IP-Tables-Regeln,
die das Ganze blocken.
Das ist schon mal schlecht.
Also die müssen wir wahrscheinlich gleich rausschmeißen.
Aber die Anwendung selbst läuft da gar nicht.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Anwendung liegt.
die wir da angeblich starten wollen.
Ist das Szenario kaputt?
Also wir können die IP-Tables-Regeln schon mal rausschmeißen, auf jeden Fall.
Also das ist zumindest schon mal ein Problem, was wir haben.
Das hier, ja.
Aber dass die Anwendung nicht läuft, ist schon mal auch...
Also, ich weiß gar nicht, wo die Anwendung liegen soll.
Sieht hier irgendwas nach Webserver aus?
ByGo hat halt einen eingebauten Webserver, ne?
Liegt da irgendwo unter Home noch was?
Ah!
Home Web App.
Das war jetzt aber auch echt nur geraten, ne?
gibt es einen user der web web app heißt
home web app
static ok hier liegt hier legt das zeug rum home web app aber die die große
preisfrage ist ja wohl liegt die anwendung an sich der stadt ist nichts
drin ist nichts drin das hätten uns die lieben entwickler
ja mit box haben wir hier
das ist box ist der rektor okay pki
Serverzertifikate?
Okay, nice.
Ja, soll ich jetzt einen Webserver installieren
oder was? Der das dann surft?
Oder wie? Ich muss die Aufgabe
nochmal lesen.
They broke the application.
Ja, wo ist denn die Application?
The fixed application should be able to...
Okay, also brauchen wir irgendeine Art
Irgendeine Art Reverse-Proxy oder sowas.
Die Idee, der HTTPS macht.
Läuft hier irgendwas,
was nach
8080?
Aber das ist was anderes, oder?
Was ist...
Ne, das Terminal als Web-Application.
Also ich sehe hier nichts laufen.
Kannst du mal schauen, was die letzten Changes waren?
Was meinst du, die History, oder was?
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung, wo ich die Anwendung finden soll.
War, www?
Gibt's nicht.
Ja, es wird schon...
Ich denke auch, dass es ein fertiges Go-Binary sein wird, aber...
Also wir brauchen zwei Sachen.
Wir brauchen erstmal die Go-Anwendung,
Wo uns die schlauen Entwickler nicht gesagt haben, wo die liegt.
Und wir brauchen einen Reverse-Proxy, der Zertifikate macht.
Und einen Lookup, einen Host-Eintrag, Web-App.
Aber das gibt es ja nicht.
Sist...
Moment.
Es gibt nen...
Es gibt nen Service, der WebUp heißt.
Ah.
Okay, da hätte ich auch so drauf kommen können.
Es gibt nen System D Service.
Gab es nicht so ein Ding?
System CTL Show oder sowas?
Web App.
Genau, da sieht man, was da...
Wir ignorieren das mal.
ETC, System, System D.
Jetzt hier gucken wir mal.
Web App.
Da ist es hier, guck.
BIM System, Web App.
Das ist der System D Service, der die...
Also.
App Static, dir.
Home, Web App Static Files.
App Search.
Server.
User-Local-Bin-Web-App.
Aha.
Okay.
Haben wir es doch gefunden.
Status.
Web-App kann nicht starten.
Warum kann das nicht starten?
Weil Permission denied auf den Zertifikatsfiles.
Okay.
Und dann
Cannot access Certificate-Key-File.
Das kriegen wir gefixt.
PKI.
Das gehört Admin.
Das ist nochmal falsch. So, dann sagen wir mal hier, CH Own Web App auf alles unterhalb von PKI.
Okay, System CTL, machen wir was anderes. Restart. Das sieht doch schon besser aus.
das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Curl
local
host
HTTPS.
Aber das Ding macht selbst HTTPS.
Okay.
Unable to get local issue certificate.
Also das Zertifikat, was da liegt,
ist
kaputt. Wenn wir das jetzt ignorieren
und sagen minus K,
dann funktioniert das halbwegs.
Das Zertifikat könnte ja auch vielleicht einfach nur für Web-App ausgestellt sein.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Wahrscheinlich ist es für Web-App ausgestellt, vermutlich.
Zeige ich mal her.
Da müssen wir OpenSSL-Stells machen.
Aber vielleicht haben wir Glück und wir sehen das.
Ah, hier.
CN ist Web-App.
CN ist das hier quasi, wenn man auf einen HTTPS Endpunkt geht, also quasi Hostname, da kann man name, muss WebApp sein.
Deswegen curlt er hier auch auf WebApp.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt noch nach etc.hosts und noch für localhost quasi einen zweiten Alias einführen, nämlich WebApp.
Wenn ich jetzt sage ping WebApp, dann pingt zumindest auch schon mal localhosts da zurück.
Und jetzt curlen wir das Ganze nochmal.
Web App
Ups, what the fuck
Okay, es gibt immer noch Probleme
mit dem Zertifikat, obwohl es Web App ist
Also ein Problem haben wir schon mal behoben
aber noch nicht alle Probleme
Unable to get local issuer
certificate
Hm.
Zertifikatssachen sind immer abfuck.
Ja.
Demo-CA.
Ach, liegt das nicht in den...
in den...
da, wo das System danach sucht.
Wo ist das?
ETC, SSL, irgendetwas
hier. ETC, muss das dahin vielleicht?
ETC,
SSL,
ähm,
Sir, ich war kurz.
Muss das quasi dahin?
Dass wir, dass wir dieser CA überhaupt
trusten? Weil aktuell
trusten wir ja,
guck mal,
Wir trusten
den Demo-CA.
Trusten wir nicht.
So.
Box. Ich habe doch eben irgendwelche
Zertifikate hier gesehen. PKI?
CA. Da ist es doch.
OpenSSL.
Okay.
No Text.
OpenSSL. Ich kann mir das nicht merken, Alter.
Hier.
OpenSSL.
No Out Text.
Genau.
Wir wollen jetzt
CA.
Die Musik, das war eben
Pokémon was?
P? Orange? Irgendwas?
Keine Ahnung.
CA?
Third.
Äh.
Oh mein.
Alter, OpenSSL. Wie?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich hier fragen soll.
Show OpenSSL
Info of
Excellent.
Genau das habe ich gesucht.
Also, wir haben hier eine CA am Start
Ist das die Demo-CA?
Das ist die Demo-CA
Hier, guckt mal, Demo-CA
Das ist genau die, die den Kram ausgestellt hat
Können jetzt noch den Hash vergleichen, aber ich gehe mal davon aus
Das ist der Zertifikats-Request
Und das ist halt quasi in PAM und CERT
So, in welchem Format muss das denn nach ETC SSL Search?
Als PAM.
Was?
unable to load certificate ist das ist das ist das brauchen auch noch hier
sieht jetzt eigentlich sieht jetzt eigentlich okay aus
Also das sieht jetzt eigentlich erstmal okay aus.
Muss ich jetzt?
Boah, Zertifikatshandling, Alter.
ETC, SSL, CERN.
So, wisst ihr was? Ich kopiere diesen ganzen Krempel jetzt einfach mal dahin.
Also den CSR, den werden wir höchstwahrscheinlich nicht brauchen.
Was steht denn eigentlich, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Open SSL.
Was steht denn eigentlich in Server?
Es soll eigentlich das sein, was ich eben bekommen habe, oder?
Okay, Issue als Demo, CA.
Und wo ist der CN?
Ach hier, hier ist der CN.
Web App, okay, das ist gleich.
Ja, dann kopiere ich das halt einfach mal.
Welchem User muss der Kram gehören?
What the fuck?
Anscheinend ist es nicht gedacht, dass man das da hinlegt.
Aber wir können jetzt trotzdem mal.
Unable to get local issue sent.
Uff, Leute, Zertifikatshandling unter Linux.
Was weiß ich denn?
Wahrscheinlich war es schon mal nicht richtig, das einfach hier hinzulegen.
Okay, die...
Berechtigungen stimmen.
Stimmen ja wahrscheinlich
auch nicht. Was hat denn so
eine, was hat denn das so für Berechtigungen?
Ah, read all.
Okay.
Also
machen wir jetzt
ch
mod 777
Ne.
machen wir jetzt.
Auf die Files.
Okay, das sieht besser aus.
Geht es jetzt?
Wir restarten nochmal.
Man weiß ja nie.
Ne.
Okay, da muss ich googeln.
Keine Ahnung, wie du das findest.
Ähm.
Hallo?
Google hat keinen Bock.
Unable to get local issue.
Ja, genau, genau.
You need to tell Curl
the location of
your trusted Hoot Certificate
Store. Try.
Okay. Das ist eine
gute Idee. Das probieren wir aus, ob das prinzipiell
geht.
ja, also ob das an sich
okay ist
wenn man dem jetzt sagt
wir wollen
ca.
cert
oder pem
okay, wenn man ihm das explizit gibt
ist alles okay
okay
probieren
das ist schon mal gut
das Funst. Also jetzt müssen wir bloß noch
checken,
wie man das
Linux sagt.
Dass er das
gefälligst nehmen soll.
Man muss, es gibt doch
irgendwie
Linux Update Trusted
Certificates. Da muss man doch
CA irgendwas machen, oder?
Da gibt es doch irgendeinen Command
dafür. Update!
Update CA Certificates.
Null added, null removed.
Done.
Ah, Moment.
Man soll diesen Mist gar nicht einfach nur dahin kopieren.
Okay, warte mal.
Ich R.M. das mal wieder.
R.M.
ist auch so ein geiles Wort.
Ich RM das mal wieder.
Und...
Alter, wie...
Ich glaub, das hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Wie funzt das?
Was macht das Ding eigentlich?
Nix? Okay. Gut.
Ah!
Man muss das
Bootbox
PKI
Man muss das CA-Cert
nach User-Local-Share
kopieren
und dann Update machen.
Aha!
One added, zero removed.
Curl!
Escape!
Okay, verbinden ist aber wahrscheinlich
immer noch nicht das, was wir haben wollen, oder?
Es geht.
Healthcheck gab es doch noch.
Also, das hätten wir. So, was
hat er hier nochmal reingeschrieben?
Should return
content of the file.
Okay, verbinden.
Verbinden kriege ich da. Das ist
tatsächlich, ich finde, das ist eine Aufgabe, die könnte
man fast schon in schwer packen, weil es sehr viele
kleine Probleme gibt. Also, wir kriegen
als Antwort verbinden. Das heißt,
wir gucken jetzt noch einmal nach home web app der dpa static files gehört gehört auch admin
admin und die an der hat kein ried drauf ok ca
Home Web App Static Files, machen wir das gleiche mal, soll alles dem gehören.
Curl. Was? Immer noch verbinden? Home Web App?
Ich restart mal.
Okay, warum ist das immer noch verbitten?
Ist das Routing?
Warte mal, warte mal.
Not found.
Okay, okay.
Also das Routing ist schon mal richtig.
Warum ist Users not found?
Wir haben doch hier noch mehr.
Static Files.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Health Check.
Geht denn Health Check?
Oder ist es da das Gleiche?
Health Check?
else check geht auch nicht.
while geht wahrscheinlich dann auch nicht.
Habe ich das Verzeichnis oben drüber vielleicht nicht?
Doch.
sudo –su webapp –i geht das?
–bim bash
Gut, jetzt sind wir User Web App.
Können wir mal gucken.
Static Files, also ob der User das prinzipiell aufmachen darf.
Ja.
Also User-Berechtigungen sind schon mal nett, die da Probleme machen.
Läuft denn die Web-App überhaupt als Web-App-User?
Ja.
Macht sie.
Hm.
Warum ist das verbinden?
Lockt das Ding dann was?
Permission denied.
What?
Moment, ich hab da eine ganz blöde Idee.
Aber Moment, wenn Permission denied...
Permission denied.
Das ist irgendein System D Ding.
Ich wette mit euch, das ist irgendein SystemD-Teil.
ETC, SystemD, SystemWebApp.
WebAppService.
Zeig mal her.
HomeWebAppStaticFiles, cert, PEM.
HomeWebAppStaticFiles, das ist richtig.
TypeSimple, UserGroup, Timeout.
Ne, okay, das ist kein SystemD-Problem.
Ich habe gedacht, hier sind vielleicht komische Dinger gesetzt oder so.
Dann probieren wir mal was anderes aus.
Lass uns das mal ausgeben.
So, wir stoppen jetzt mal den Service.
Stopp.
Und wir starten das jetzt mal von Hand.
Also sagen wir mal hier, Export, Export, Export und jetzt starten wir das mal von Hand.
Aber damit das funktioniert ist dann T-Mux drauf.
Exzellent.
Achso, ähm
Hätte ich vielleicht vorher machen sollen
Äh, what the fuck
Okay, also wo war das andere?
User, Local, Bin, Web App, ne?
Achso, ich bin jetzt ja auch root
Ist ja kein Wunder, dass das
nicht funktioniert
sudo
minus u webapp
sudo minus u
webapp
bin bash
Okay, jetzt müssen wir das ganze
nochmal machen
Zack
Zack. Und nun das mal von Hand starten. Okay. Curl. Curl. Verbinden. Was hat er denn für Probleme mit dem Static File? Hat er generell irgendwelche Probleme mit Home Web App oder so?
Ich mach jetzt mal
L-S-A-D-R-E
Static
Oh ja, Sternchen
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was E bedeutet?
Ich nicht
Explain
Ah, geh weg
Extent Format is being used
Okay, das ist irgendwas anderes
Das hat damit nichts zu tun
Okay, der benutzt auch keine
Warum ist das
Permission denied?
Ich hätte hier mal eine klar reiche Idee.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Touch
touch
blub.html
als
als Web App.
Touch
blub
blub.html
Curl
Auch vorbitten.
Moment, da muss doch irgendwas...
Irgendwas stimmt doch hier mit den Files nicht.
Aber es haben alle Reader drauf.
Wie kann das...
Warum steht da eine Readme-Datei?
Doch, doch, doch.
Die Zertifikate kann er
davon da auch lesen.
So.
Also, was könnte das sein?
So, was? Wir machen jetzt mal folgendes.
Wir backuppen uns das Ding mal.
Oh, man.
Das war jetzt schon mal Fail, was ich gemacht habe.
Minus P.
Was die Web App macht?
Ich habe den Source Code nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist Teil der Aufgabe.
So, Web App.
Und jetzt waren wir hier.
CH Mod 777.
Minus R.
Web App.
Bam.
Gucken, ob es das jetzt fixt.
Aber ich glaube, das ist irgendwo was
fieses eingebaut.
Okay, verbinden.
Es ist 777 und es ist immer noch
verbinden.
Also das kann schon mal nicht das Problem sein.
Wir gucken mal kurz
nochmal in den Check rein.
Okay, mehr erkennen wir da auch jetzt nicht an der Stelle.
SE-Linux?
Fragezeichen, Leute.
Ah!
SE-Linux!
Beziehungsweise App-Armor, nicht SE-Linux.
Ich schalte das jetzt einfach aus.
System, System, CTL, stopp.
Wie macht man das so?
App-Armor, bam.
Oh, shit.
Habe ich jetzt kaputt gemacht?
Ja.
Immer noch verbinden.
Das muss man bestimmt nochmal neu starten, hä?
Verbinden, fuck.
Aber es ist, es ist, chat.
Minus T für die Zeit.
Ähm, App-Armor-Stoppen hat nichts gebracht, Leute.
Das läuft bestimmt immer noch.
Ähm.
Fuck, wie...
Okay.
Ubuntu-Disable-App-Armor.
Ah, ah, Teardown
muss man machen, okay.
Haha!
Excellent!
Wir haben die Security Measures einfach wieder ausgeschaltet.
Easy!
Wer braucht das schon?
Security Measures deaktiviert und schon
funktioniert es.
Check.
No.
Was? No?
Moment, Health Check geht immer noch nicht.
Och.
Achso, ich hab's ja noch hier laufen.
Ich muss den System...
den Service wieder starten.
Okay, Service läuft wieder
Curlen wir nochmal den Health-Check
Jawohl, und jetzt Check
Okay, gut
Wir haben es gelöst, Leute
Jetzt sind die Security-Measures wieder weg
Ja, das stimmt schon
Wollen wir mal gucken, was denn die
Also, wollen wir mal gucken
Ob wir es richtig gelöst haben
Wir können uns nämlich mal die Hinweise angucken dazu.
Also, Chat, wir sind uns einig, es funktioniert.
Ja, ist alles gut.
Gucken wir mal, was wir für Clues bekommen hätten.
Erster Clue.
Journal CTL.
Okay, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich bin irgendwie um drei Ecken drauf gekommen,
dass es ein System D-Service ist.
Ich hätte auch gleich mal PSAux Web App oder so machen können.
Aber okay. Egal, ich hab's rausgekriegt.
So, nächster ist
Fixed File Permissions.
Das haben wir mehr oder weniger
so gemacht in zwei Schritten.
Zertifikatstells.
Haben wir auch gemacht.
ETC Hosts haben wir auch gemacht.
Ich hab einen Alias zu
zu low-close hinzugefügt.
Kommt aufs Gleiche raus.
Ähm.
App-Armor.
Ja.
There is an App-Armor
profile for the application.
Ach was. Wir haben die Security Measures
ausgeschaltet. Ich finde unsere Lösung ist viel besser.
Okay.
Zack. Check my solution.
X-Solution.
Also wir haben die Security Measures
wieder ausgeschaltet. Aber wichtig ist nur, dass am Ende
rauskommt, funktioniert. Okay?
Destroy Server.
Ähm. Ich hoffe,
der hat das jetzt gecheckt, dass ich
das gelöst hab. Hat er das
gecheckt?
Äh, Moment. Welches war das eben?
Ja, sieh. 21
war das, ne? Okay, er hat's
gecheckt.
Gut.
Man muss sagen, Chat, gar keine so einfache Aufgabe, oder?
Muss ich doch zwischendurch ein bisschen nachdenken, was da Sache ist.
Was meint ihr, hätte man das auch in schwer packen können?
So richtig schwer war es jetzt nicht, aber es war halt viel und unterschiedliche Sachen.
Ich finde, das hätte man in einer der oberen Aufgaben von schwer packen können.
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, es wäre nach der Schwierigkeit.
War schon schwierig, ne?
So, was haben wir jetzt gesagt, machen wir als nächstes.
Das hier.
Potsdam.
Helmschad-Issue.
Oh, nee.
Please, keine Helmschads.
Helmschads.
Nein, Gott! Nein, Gott, bitte, nein! Nein! Nein! Nein!
engine exalt however er bekommt die default engine exalte you can check for example was
hier pot ipc der blubber ein kölner ip in edition ich schütze trippi cast 23 ok
the chart is not working as expected fix the configuration so you get the custom
html-page von any engine export
ich mag die helm syntax nichts das ist diese go template syntax ich finde das so
eklig
leider gibt es keine wirkliche alternative dazu
dass es gibt halt nichts, was ähnlich verbreitet ist.
Und
war ich fast schon Standard.
Die Helmcharts.
Es
Okay.
All das ist CubeCTL get
Pots minus A. Immer erstmal
checken, was da so läuft.
Ein Traffic läuft.
Ups.
Wollte ich gar nicht.
traffic läuft mit ricks webchart jeder ist das webchart engine x ging's ging's
wie die auf die idee kommen dass man das engine x ausspricht weiß ich auch nicht
also man spricht das so aus aber versucht es niemand würde das engine x
aussprechen wenn man das nicht wüsste man würde es nix oder so aussprechen
also da machen wir das doch mal hier pot ip zack bäum und dann wird gekurlt
Welcome to Nginx
Also wir können das nach
Oder Nginx
Nginx wäre auch nicht schlecht
Nginx finde ich fast noch besser
Okay
Wo liegt denn dieses hässliche Helmchart rum?
Machen wir erstmal Helm List All.
Oh, Webchart.
Da ist es.
Zack, Webchart.
Hier ist es.
Guck da.
Bam.
Jetzt müssen wir uns das Helmchart mal angucken.
Also wir gucken erst mal kurz in die Jammer.
In die Values rein.
Das sieht so aus, als muss es uns nicht großartig interessieren.
Ach, Chat.
Äh, ja.
Hä, warum wurde diese Nachricht denn jetzt blockiert?
TomRider94, keine Ahnung.
Deine Nachricht wurde geblockt.
Warum?
Ich habe es jetzt schon allowed.
Jetzt müsste es eigentlich, genau.
Hallo, ich habe eine Frage zu meinem
Linux 2404 LTS.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich von meinem Laptop
boote, reagiert er nicht mehr auf
den linken Mausklick.
Über das Trackpad oder über eine
externe Maus?
also keine ahnung also mit der ssd wird das wahrscheinlich nichts zu tun haben
und mit einem laptop modell wahrscheinlich auch nicht
hast du mal probiert ein aktuelles linux zu booten vom usb stick
ist chat ist ist 24 04 lts ist das schon weiland oder ist das noch x wisst ihr das
ich glaube das schon weiland 24 04 das heißt mit irgendwelche xx input device konflikt kommt
man da nicht weiter also ich würde mal von einem live usb stick booten und gucken ob
ob das dann funktioniert.
Und ich würde die Maus mal woanders anschließen
und gucken, ob da der linke Mausklick funktioniert.
Nur mal so ein bisschen zum Ausschließen.
Also mit deiner Samsung-SSD kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das damit irgendwas zu tun hat.
Und dein Notebook wird auch nicht kaputt sein.
Okay, machen wir weiter.
Hier sind wir.
Also das sieht doch alles okay aus hier
Ah ne okay Replika Count das können wir auf 3 stellen
Sollten wir eben auch schon machen
Pots minus A
Ja hier sehen wir auch das gibt es nur einfach
Über den Stick ist das eine Katastrophe
Weil der Anschluss arschlangsam ist
Wieso was ist denn das
Wie alt ist denn das Ding
Oh, shit
Okay, das ist schon ein bisschen älter
Dass das so alt ist, hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht
Was ist denn da so drin?
Weiß man nicht.
Findet man, findet man.
Intel Pentium.
Okay, immerhin schon ein Dual-Core.
3 GB DDR.
Alter, das ist ja mal richtig alt.
Was ist denn das?
USB 2 wird das noch sein, oder?
Ach, das geht schon.
Hau dir ein Linux-Mint auf einen USB-Stick drauf und bote das mal.
Und dann guck mal, ob da ein Links-Klick funktioniert.
Das geht schon.
Das geht schon über USB 2.
Ich habe auch schon zig Linux-Server über USB gebootet.
Das ist gar kein Ding.
Also das ist doch das Einzige, was da übrig bleibt.
Die Maus anschließen, mal einen anderen Computer gucken, ob die geht.
und dann mal USB-Stick booten und gucken, ob das geht.
Da hast du schon mal ausgeschlossen, dass es was mit dem Laptop ist,
beziehungsweise dass es was mit der Maus ist.
Und danach musst du mal gucken, was für Settings sind.
Aber ansonsten, die Sachen müsstest du jetzt schon erstmal machen.
Sonst wüsste ich auch nicht, wo man ansetzen könnte.
Also das müsstest du dir jetzt mal angucken.
Das geht schon.
Das ist... Dann bootet es halt 10 Minuten. So what?
So, aber jetzt müssen wir ja erstmal zurück zu unserem eigentlichen Problem.
Wir haben nämlich nicht viel Zeit. Wir haben nur 30 Minuten Zeit.
Und wir haben schon 7 Minuten verplempert.
Also Replikas haben wir auf 3 gestellt. Das ist okay.
Das sollten wir auch machen.
Und dann bekommt die Default-Engine-X-Seite anstatt die Custom-Engine-X-Seite.
Dann gucken wir mal kurz, ob hier Version und was da drin steht.
Okay, aber nix.
Templates.
ähm, Config Map
Deployment
So viel wird das nicht sein.
Okay, so, ja.
Also, Config Map
Ich muss das tatsächlich mal so machen.
Aha.
Index HTML. Ah, das kommt aus
der Config Map und das wird dann reingemountet
in den Pod wahrscheinlich.
Gilt die Chat-Kontrolle auch
im Twitch-Chat? Ja.
Okay.
Also Index HTML
kommt aus der Config Map.
Service, da müssen wir wahrscheinlich
nichts anpassen.
Ich würde jetzt einfach mal sagen,
das stimmt, dann müssen wir im Deployment
einfach nur die Index
HTML mounten, würde ich mal sagen.
Das kann ich mir
auch immer nicht aus dem Kopf merken, wie man das
genau macht.
Image, ja, hier fehlt
hier fehlt eindeutig
das Mountain
der Index HTML
ja
by the way, was für ein Image benutzt
er eigentlich
hat
values
er benutzt image tag
ich will mal kurz gucken ob man sich da rein execken kann cubectl exec
minus it ich kann mir das immer nicht merken minus minus default namespace
und jetzt bin bash bin bash
Minus, Minus, Minus
Okay, da sind wir
Alles klar, wir sind in den Container reingeexekt
War www
Ne, Moment, wo kommt denn überhaupt
Die Webseite her
Die der ausliefert
Wo bringt der
Wo holt sich der Nginx das denn her
Wo ist denn die Nginx Conf
ETC Engine X
Engine X
Oh gut, das gibt es natürlich jetzt nicht
Engine X Conf
Conf D
Default Conf, da sind wir
Also hier
Port 80
User Share Engine X
HTML, da müssen wir das rein
Mounten, da muss die Index HTML hin
User Share.
Das ist die Default-Engineering-Seite.
Okay, dann weiß ich wenigstens,
was das Problem ist.
Also hier, das müssen wir
noch speichern. Da müssen wir dann
unsere Index-HTML reinmountain jetzt.
Also, dann machen wir
das doch mal. Wim, erwartet von mir
jetzt aber, please nicht, dass ich das aus dem Kopf hinkriege.
Wir können...
Ah, wisst ihr was?
Wir machen mal was anderes.
Wir probieren mal was aus.
Cube CTL Edit.
Edit. Deployment.
Bevor wir das ins Helmchart eintragen,
editieren wir das einfach mal von Hand.
So.
Jamel. Mount. Config. Map.
File.
Configure port to use a config map.
Genau.
Haben wir, haben wir, haben wir.
Auch das Jamel dafür.
Ja, genau, genau.
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Das brauchen wir alles nicht.
Haben wir doch alles schon.
Niemand kann sich diesen Krempel merken, ey.
Hier, das brauchen wir.
Also, hier.
Das da.
Nicht wirklich ein Weihrauch.
Wir wollen es als Pfeil mounten.
Das geht.
Ich kann mir nur nicht...
...nicht merken, wie...
Volume, ja, Volume.
Recht, Volume.
Ah, Add Config...
Das da, das da, das such ich.
Genau, das such ich.
Hier, das da.
Exzellent, genau.
Also erstmal brauchen wir das hier.
Das muss hier unterhalb von
Spec.
Quasi.
Containers.
Moment.
Ich will nicht das Deployment editieren.
Ich will den Pod editieren.
Wie geht das?
Speck, Konti...
Ach, guck mal. Hier sind ja auch schon ein paar Volume-Mounts.
Also, wir brauchen...
Hier gibt es auch Volumes.
So, hier brauchen wir erstmal unterhalb von...
Config Map?
Okay, das heißt, wir brauchen das hier
unterhalb.
Ja.
Das ist immer so eine abartige Syntax.
Nee, ich will das Deployment nicht editieren, oder?
Muss man den Pod neu starten, dass das funktioniert mit dem Mountain?
Ja, dann muss ich das Deployment editieren.
Ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Wir machen das jetzt einfach direkt über das Helm-Chart.
Deployment, Jamel.
Also wir brauchen einmal hier
Name, Conf, Volume.
Das da im Prinzip.
Den da.
Das muss...
Hier drunter...
Hier drunter muss das, ne?
Containers? Ah ne, Moment, Moment.
Es muss auf...
Es muss auf Höhe von Containers.
Ja doch, hab ich doch richtig.
Passt doch.
Set Paste.
Der will uns schon sagen, wenn das syntaktisch nicht stimmt.
Bin ich jetzt hier richtig eingerückt? Ja.
ok gut
ok also name config volume config map name wie hieß die config map cubectl get
config maps web charts index html
So macht man das so.
Okay, ja.
So macht man das.
Gut. Und jetzt
brauchen wir noch ein Volume Mount.
Das muss dann quasi unterhalb,
das muss dann quasi hier rein.
Hab ich schon mal gesagt,
das Jamme, übelste Abfuck, ist immer
Äh
Wait a minute
Hier, oder?
Oh, Jamel
Moment
Fuck
So?
Nee, Moment
Jamel, stell's, Alter
Okay, so, ha?
So, so, so müsste es stimmen.
So müsste es stimmen.
Auf der Höhe von Image, okay?
Mount Path ETC Config.
Ne, Mount Path User Share.
User Share Engine X HTML.
Was ist denn in dieser Config Map überhaupt drin?
Da haben wir doch schon mal reingeguckt.
Da ist nur die Index HTML drin.
Okay, also von der Idee her müsste das eigentlich funktionieren.
Michael, 50 Milliarden, moin! Dankeschön für den Sub.
Hock!
Dazu kann ich nur sagen...
Okay, Helm...
Moment, aber guck mal, ob ich das aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege.
Helm, Upgrade, Minus, Minus, Install, falls es nicht installiert ist.
ähm, minus n
default, na gut, brauchen wir nicht
minus n default minus f
mal hell
minus list a
hell
ich hab's doch hier irgendwo gehabt
hell upgrade install minus f
f ist das value file
values yaml
und das chart ist
punkt
Ich hoffe, das stimmt, was ich hier bastle, Alter.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Das wäre auch zu einfach gewesen.
Muss vielleicht...
Was habe ich vergessen?
Ach, Name habe ich vergessen.
Webchart.
Deswegen ist Bash Syntax...
Tags. Äh, nicht, ich bin, ähm,
Bash History
ist die beste...
Ah, so ging das. Okay.
Bash History ist
die beste Doku ever.
So.
Was?
Ah, not found.
Ah, Konfliktvolumen nicht gefunden.
Habe ich mich irgendwie vertippt?
Sim-Templates?
Also hier habe ich ja nichts dran gemacht.
Deployment?
Warte mal, bin ich richtig?
Was hat er?
Cannot patch?
Kein Diplom-Web-Chart.
NGINX ist invalid.
Volume-Mounts.
Not found. Config-Volume.
Habe ich mich da irgendwie vertippt?
Ne.
Doch richtig?
Oder ist das an der falschen Stelle?
Oh Gott, wie ich Jammer editieren hasse von Hand.
Ah, ich hab das an der falschen Stelle stehen.
Volumes muss nicht dahin.
Volumes muss wahrscheinlich noch weiter.
Ja, natürlich.
Natürlich.
Volumes muss weiter rein.
Wo muss das hin?
Volumes muss auf die...
Moment.
Volumes muss auf die gleiche Höhe
wie Containers.
Habe ich das jetzt?
Naja, habe ich nicht.
Jetzt aber, oder?
Perfekt.
Okay, jetzt nochmal Upgrade, Install, bam.
Hat funktioniert.
Yeah.
Ja.
Guck mal, wir haben auch drei Replikas am Start.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob alles prinzipiell funktioniert hat, was wir gemacht haben.
Also wir müssen nach...
Dahin mal gucken.
Index HTML.
Äh.
Ja, das sieht gut aus.
Das sieht gut aus.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir es gefixt haben.
Machen wir nochmal diesen Kram hier.
Und dann hinten dran gleich Curl.
Wir haben es geschafft, Leute.
Kubernetes wurde gefixt.
Replikas zu 3.
Check my solution.
Bam.
Kubernetes-Yammel-Stells am Start.
Jetzt habt ihr es mal live gesehen,
warum ich immer so am Meckern bin
über Yammel- bzw. Kubernetes-Yammel-Files.
Das ist so wirr.
Das kannst du, also das, es ergibt schon Sinn, was drinnen steht, wenn man es liest, ja.
Aber das zu erstellen, du musst auf Einrückung achten, da musst du gucken, okay, wie war das jetzt, auf welche Höhe wusste das Volume, wo mussten die Volume-Mounts hin, ist das Volume-Mounts dafür oder ist es Volumes dafür?
Das ist echt...
Ja, wie soll ich es anders editieren?
Ich habe ja nur SSH auf den Serverzugang.
In dem Fall bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit auch schon viele, viele YAML-Files mit Vim editiert.
Und ich habe auch genauso viele YAML-Files schon irgendwie in KI hingeschmissen.
Hab gesagt, ey, guck mal, warum geht der Kram nicht?
Aber schön ist es auf jeden Fall nicht.
So, haben wir geschafft.
Chat, ihr dürft euch ein neues Szenario aussuchen.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal die Szenarien zwischen 21 und 8 und...
Ne, Moment.
Zwischen 16 und 25 machen wir jetzt erstmal.
Also die zwei haben wir jetzt gemacht.
Könnt ihr euch noch was anderes raussuchen hier.
Ich mach mal größer, dass ihr es besser erkennen könnt hier.
Also die...
Die neun haben wir jetzt zur Auswahl.
Also, naja, eigentlich nicht. Also sieben.
Wollt ihr noch irgendwas Spezielles sehen?
22, 23, 22, 19.
Okay, wir machen einfach alle.
Fangen wir aber an.
Fangen wir an in der Reihenfolge, wie es der Chat geschrieben hat.
22, 23, 19.
Helsingor.
Postgres Physical Replication.
MonkaS.
Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die...
Okay, es gibt drei Sachen, die ultra abfuck sind.
Datenbank Replizierung.
Zertifikatsmanagement.
und YAML-Files per CLA editieren.
Wobei es gibt bestimmt noch deutlich mehr Sachen,
die abfuck sind.
You are setting up a PostgresQL-Data-Base
with replication.
You decided to use Docker
with Docker Compose.
Oh, Istio, ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Istio ist auch abfuck.
wobei google das ja als anthos oder so verkauft aber das ist ja das ist ja okay
wir benutzen docker compose um das easier zu machen und einfacher zu testen
nach vielen stunden harter arbeit ist der job finished und die master
datenbank ist up and running ich habe trouble mit den replikas von
postgres absolut kein blassen schimmer von so wir müssen outfigern was mit der
replika falsch läuft so und nachdem er doch ein kompons verwenden kann ich hier
mit checken ob das funst loks ja ja dass das dass das weiß ich
leute ich habe keine ich habe absolut keine ahnung von postgres application
Aber gucken wir mal.
Oh, warum ist die Musik aus?
Warte mal.
Da lerne ich noch was, Chat.
Chat, wer von euch hat schon mal
Postgres Replication von Hand aufgesetzt?
Also ich habe es noch nie gemacht.
So wie es aussieht, hat Chat auch nicht.
Es ist ganz einfach.
Die Datenbank, die darf einfach nicht neu gestartet werden
oder irgendwie down gehen.
Dann braucht man auch nur eine.
Einfach nichts kaputt gehen lassen.
Easy.
Das ist genauso, wie ich letztens ein Video gesehen habe.
How to win the Tour de France
Einfach schneller fahren als die anderen
Das ist doch easy
Einfach vor den anderen ankommen
Vorherd
Weiß auch nicht, warum die da nicht drauf kommen
Oh, ich wollte heute eigentlich Tour de France schauen
Warte mal, warte mal
Was gibt es denn heute für eine
Achte Etappe
Achte Etappe.
Profil. Was gibt's denn heute?
Okay, langweilig.
Was ist DevSecBiz
was ich mir ausgedacht hab?
Das ist einer,
der
sich um
DevSecBiz
Bits,
Vin,
Lin und Ops kümmert.
Hab ich so noch nie gelesen, ne?
Aber was ich schon gelesen hab,
ist, ist, äh,
Dev, Vin, Zack, Ops
hab ich schon gelesen.
Gut, also auf geht's.
Helsingor.
Leute, keine Ahnung von Postcast Replication, aber wir probieren es einfach mal.
SSH.
Zack.
Yes.
Erstmal Docker.
Guck, Docker PS.
Äh.
Warum hängt das?
Chat, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es docker ps-A gibt.
Aber anscheinend schon.
Ach nee, gibt es nicht.
Und man hätte jetzt einfach eine halbe Stunde gebraucht, bis er gecheckt hat, dass es minus A nicht gibt, oder was?
Also, das hier kackt immer ab.
Starting, restart.
Wobei, nee, kackt der immer ab?
Muss man mal schauen, ob der immer abkackt.
Nicht ganz sicher.
Ja.
Okay, der kackt immer ab.
Die DB-Replika
kackt immer ab.
So, wir gucken jetzt erstmal.
Wir gucken jetzt erstmal
das Docker-Compose-File.
Oh, mehr Text, please.
Äh.
Chat, kann mir irgendjemand erklären,
was für eine abartige Syntax das hier ist.
Ist das
Variablen-Referenzieren
im Jammel oder so?
Das ist Variablen-Referenzieren.
Hier oben, genau. Guck mal, hier wird
dieser... Oh Gott!
Jammel-Variablen, Alter!
Wer macht denn sowas? Da ist
der...
Da brennen
dir ja gleich die Augen durch.
Das hier kannst du dann quasi
da einsetzen lassen.
habe ich schon mal gesehen ich habe es aber selbst noch nie geschrieben weil
ich weiß nicht fehlt mir so das anwendungsding also zeig mal her
test pg ist ready als dieser user
ausgleich ist auch mega neustadt alles post ist vielleicht ist was ganz besonders spezialisiert
das schneller als postgres in manchen bereichen ja also wenn du nur no sql braucht ist wahrscheinlich
eine neue datenbank besser wenn du nur time series daten braucht ist wahrscheinlich keine
influx db oder so besser aber wenn du kommst oder wenn du text search brauchst ist wahrscheinlich was
sind da aktuell angesagt. Keine Ahnung.
Lucene oder so. Besser.
Aber wenn du eine Kombination aus allem brauchst
und eine relationale Datenbank, ist Postgres beste.
Chat, ich verstehe nicht, was hier
überhaupt passiert.
Postgres Host Auth Method.
Scram Chart
256.
Host.
Replication all.
Von allen trusted.
Okay, das ist der Master.
Der Master akzeptiert von überall Verbindungen.
Rate ich jetzt einfach mal.
Postgres User.
Postgres Passwort.
Da ist bestimmt irgendein Fehler drin.
Wir müssen uns mal die Logs angucken vom Crashing Container.
Und dann.
Mountet er hier den Kram rein
Startet Postgres mit der Config
So, jetzt kommt das Postgres Replika
Ports
Stimmen denn die Ports schon einmal?
Sind denn die Ports schon einmal richtig?
5, 4, 3, 3
Na gut
Wahrscheinlich
Postgres Passwort Replikator
Muss das Postgres Passwort
Das von da oben sein
Wobei der Trusted ja von überall
Volumes Postgres Conf
Command
Postgres Data
Okay das ist was der beim Startup ausführt
Until
PG Base
stream ver...
Alter.
Okay, wir gucken mal in die Logs rein.
Ich hab legit absolut keinen blassen Schimmer,
weil ich noch nie Postcards Replication gemacht hab.
Äh, Docker...
Docker Compose.
Gibt's sowas da?
Ja.
Docker Compose.
Oder müssen wir Docker Compose verwenden?
So, was können wir da jetzt machen?
logs stand doch eben da ja das will ich logs postgres db replika
re warum auto komplete der das nicht ist der dumm ja da ist um also was macht er
denn hier wenn er startet recovery aborted because of insufficient parameter settings
you can reset the server after making the necessary conflict changes start up process exited
ok max connections
also ok max connections muss ich die dann auf 100 ich leute ich habe mich
jetzt nur an den an den dingen an den an den an den fehlermeldungen lang keine
ahnung auskürzt config 80 steht da angeblich irgendwas drin okay das schreibt
das schreiben wir da schon mal schreiben wir da schon mal 100 hin
ok doch gibt es gibt es so was wie docker compose restart oder sowas
Wow, Alter
Ist das geil
Advanced Shit
Gibt es auch sowas wie minus F?
Hoho
Also
Starting
Insufficient Max Worker Processes
Das muss auf 8.
Worker.
Processors.
Auf 8.
Restart.
Okay.
Ah, Moment.
Was hat er denn hier?
Achso, Alter.
Soll ich das ja alles von Hand
anpassen oder wie? Oder kann ich
einfach die
Postgres-Config
rüber kopieren?
Diff, das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Das ist eine exzellente Idee.
Master,
Postgres-Config, Replika,
Postgres-Config.
Okay, anscheinend
ist es nicht viel.
Es ist nicht viel.
Also hier die
die die die wahl timmy timmy sender auf 10
replica postgres auf 10
riest okay wie oft habe ich das schon wieder aber ich es auch übersehen eben
was war das jetzt 64
Okay
Dies
Okay, das sieht doch jetzt schon
Das sieht doch schon besser aus
Backup done, restarting Replica
Oh mein, mein, mein
Aber Probleme hat er immer noch gehabt, oder?
Oder nicht?
AM cannot remove
und Connection
refused.
Nee, das, das, das,
der, der, Moment, war's das jetzt schon, oder was?
War's das jetzt?
Okay.
Ja, das war jetzt easy.
Da musstest du dich mit Postcards Replication nicht wirklich auskennen, oder?
Du musstest...
Du musstest im Endeffekt einfach nur...
Fehlermeldungen dir angucken und...
Fehlermeldungen...
sich langhangeln.
Das war... Okay, das war easy.
Okay, nächstes
Als nächstes sollten wir, eben haben wir das hier gemacht
Als nächstes sollten wir 23 machen
Ja, hat der Chat gesagt
Wo war das hier?
23 und dann 19
Also wenn ihr
Ihr könnt übrigens auch, wenn ihr wollt
Set-Servers bei euch daheim
Aufmachen und die gesamte
Die gesamte Sache hier durchgucken
und mir eine Aufgabe sagen,
die ihr sehen wollt.
Falls es eine Aufgabe ist,
die ich schon gemacht habe,
und ihr die unbedingt erklärt haben wollt,
können wir die auch nochmal machen.
Für einen Prime-Sub.
Bisschen Sellout muss sein.
Was haben wir jetzt als nächstes?
Supervisor is still around. Okay.
Also wir haben jetzt gesagt, wir machen
das und danach machen wir
das.
Also was haben wir denn hier?
Es läuft ein Nginx, ne ein
Nginx, ein Nginx Service
running auf Port 443.
So, das ist
der Main Web Server for the Company.
Ja, das ist eh eine gute Idee,
auf einer 2-Kern-AWS-Kiste
das laufen zu lassen.
Und ein neuer Mitarbeiter
hat Changes deployed.
Ah, nee, nee, nee.
Er hat Konfigurationen zu Supervisor, wahrscheinlich Supervisor D
oder sowas deployed.
Das ist not working as expected.
Das ist ein Fehlersuchspiel.
Übungsding. Ja, genau.
Das ist ein bisschen
sowas wie ctf sachen im security bereich oder oder lied code sachen für die
programmierer
es ist schon return hallo set servers macht es aber nicht okay supervisor die
Alter, das habe ich zuletzt vor 15 Jahren oder so gesehen.
Wir checken übrigens jetzt erst einmal, ob überhaupt der Hausname auflöst.
Neue Mitarbeiter feuern, Problem gelöst.
Neue Mitarbeiter feuern und Snapshot vom Server aus letzter Nacht zurückspielen.
Easy, Problem gelöst.
Wir hatten mal einen, ich glaube, das habe ich schon erzählt.
Recycle-Story, Leute.
Wir hatten mal einen Storage-Experten bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Der hatte anscheinend weniger Ahnung von Storage, als man so vermutet hat.
In seiner ersten Woche, wo er da war, hat er das Intervisan-Routing falsch konfiguriert.
Fragt mich bitte nicht, was es genau ist.
Irgendwelche Storage-Magic.
Intervisan-Routing.
Falsch konfiguriert.
Hat gemerkt, also auf dem produktiven Storage, ja.
Hat gemerkt, ups, jetzt ist es ja kaputt.
und dass keiner auf ihn kommt, ist er dann erstmal
drei Stunden weggegangen. Mittagessen
oder so. Also er wusste, dass er es
kaputt gemacht hat. Er ist einfach drei Stunden abgehauen.
Einfach gelieft. Ragequit.
Ragequit.
Und da haben die ewig
gesucht, bis sie es gefunden haben
und sie haben natürlich rausgefunden
und gesehen in den Logs, wer es gewesen ist
und als er dann mittags wieder
kam oder nachmittags,
wurde er raus eskortiert.
Hast du das neue Programmers are also humans Video gesehen?
Ist das der Typ, der immer diese Videos macht hier?
Diese Interview mit einem C++ Entwickler und sowas.
Moin, Dankeschön für den Sub. 84 Jahre.
Boah, fast schon in Rente.
Ja, Flatpack kann manchmal auch Painschampig sein.
Ich kenne von dem, ich kenne von dem das Interview mit den, ach der Kid, das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ich kenne von dem das Interview, wo er auf so einer Blockchain-Konferenz war und da übelst rumgememt hat und die Leute haben es halt alle ernst genommen.
raus eskortiert, ja?
Der wurde von der Security abgeholt und rausgebracht.
Hat, glaube ich, Hausverbot bis heute.
Wir müssen uns jetzt mal auf die...
Oh, okay, da ist ein Haus...
Wir müssen uns jetzt mal auf die Aufgabe konzentrieren.
Wir haben bloß 40 Minuten Zeit.
Curl, fail to start the server.
Please check the setup.
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wenn so eine Antwort kommt, dann läuft der Server doch.
Sonst wird das ja nicht als Antwort kommen.
Der Server läuft doch.
200.
Also das passt schon.
Ich darf keine Files modifien.
Aus diesem Folder.
Okay.
Na dann machen wir das doch auch mal.
Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen geht das nicht.
So.
Wir sollten vielleicht erstmal kurz gucken.
Was sagt er? Da läuft ein Engine X.
Gucken wir mal.
Da läuft tatsächlich ein Engine X.
Und da läuft auch ein Supervisor wahrscheinlich.
Ja, Supervisor D läuft da.
ETC ist Supervisor.
Habe ich gut? Habe ich nicht.
Supervisor D-Conf.
Dürfen wir den Web-Server starten und einen eigenen starten?
Ja, das könnten wir wahrscheinlich stoppen und das könnten wir wahrscheinlich machen.
Okay, Chat. Keine Ahnung von Supervisor D, aber wir haben keine...
Okay, wir haben offiziell keine Root-Rechte, okay?
Inoffiziell haben wir Root-Rechte.
Weil Docker... Weil wir Zugriff auf Docker haben.
Aber offiziell haben wir keine Root-Rechte, okay?
Also wir müssen das ohne Root-Rechte machen.
Wir könnten mit Docker austricksen und root werden.
Aber wir tun mal so, als hätten wir da keinen Docker und könnten da nicht ausbrechen.
Okay, und woher weiß man jetzt?
ETC.
Was gibt es hier?
Konf.de.
Ui.
CGI?
Nee.
Also, hier ist das Command.
Home, Admin,
BKC,
Ben Uwusgi,
Ini,
Asi-Dateien dürfen wir nicht editieren hier.
User Admin.
Okay.
Also, was darf ich nicht machen?
Ich darf,
cannot modify files moment cannot modify bedeutet dass ich darf auch keine berechtigung ändern oder
nur den inhalt aber berechtigung bringt mir gar nichts habe ich ja irgend jemand eine ahnung wie
man supervisor wie man das benutzt wie benutzt man supervisor ctr
ich muss mir ich muss mir mal den check angucken was man jetzt darf und was man
nicht darf okay okay okay die schauen sogar ob ich dateien geändert habe
Guck mal.
Die gucken sogar nach, ob ich die Dateien modifiziert habe oder nicht.
Also, woher kommt denn überhaupt Failed-to-Start-Server?
Woher kommt denn das?
Rep?
Hier.
bekasi pi fail to start server please check the setup
okay was macht was macht der denn da überhaupt es ist sehr übersichtlich
check env
ok ok da kommen wir der sache da kommen wir der sache schon näher also wenn
BKC Server und BKC User.
Wenn die gesetzt sind, dann funktioniert es.
Ansonsten Fail to Start Server.
So, die große Preisfrage wäre jetzt natürlich.
Also ich habe ja keine Root-Rechte.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier
Ich kann jetzt hier auch gar nichts machen
Aber ich hab
Ride-Rechte als Admin
Okay
Ich hab Ride-Rechte
Als Admin hier drinnen
Wie
Okay, wie setzt man
Wie setzt man
environment variablen supervisor die environment variables kann sie check
sh anpassen das würde wahrscheinlich funktioniert
Okay, also so.
Also quasi...
BK User Kekke.
Und dann was?
Komma?
Was war das andere?
Server?
Omega-Lul.
Du meinst lokale Sachen?
Ne, habe ich nichts mehr laufen.
Ich habe eine ganze Weile
Onama und
LM Studio laufen.
Aber die ganz ehrlich, lokale Models sind einfach nicht so geil.
Aber halt, private.
Woher weiß ich denn jetzt eigentlich,
ob dieser Supervisor
ob der das
jetzt neu gestartet hat oder nicht?
Hat er nicht.
Kann ich sagen?
Supervisor
CTL
Status
Wie heißt das Ding?
Naja.
Kann er nicht.
Okay.
Darf ich das zu tun?
Ach, das darf ich zu tun.
Restart.
Bekasi.
Ja.
Fail to start.
Okay.
Ey, Alter, was hab ich falsch gemacht?
Das ist die...
Ich hab wahrscheinlich einfach die Syntax verkackt, oder?
Wir gucken uns nochmal kurz die...
Ne, äh, wo war das hier drin?
Also der ganze Kram, der muss einfach nur gesetzt sein.
Get Env, Bekasi Server, Bekasi User.
Hab ich doch.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist die Sonntags falsch.
Okay, die
quoten das hier alles.
Muss ich das auch quoten vielleicht?
Aber hier oben quoten die das ja auch nicht.
Muss man vielleicht da die Files neu einlesen, dass da das richtig macht?
Ähm.
Supervisor D.
Reload-Files
oder so, dass der das überhaupt checkt.
Ja.
Supervisor D Reload.
Äh.
Ja, wie jetzt?
Supervisor
CTL Reload, so.
Restart Supervisor.
Okay, restart Big Hasi.
Und jetzt geht's, ha?
Easy!
Get schreckt!
Easy.
Ich hoffe, dass ich Supervisor D nie wieder in the wild irgendwo sehen muss, ja?
Das guck ich morgen.
Das AI-Interview guck ich morgen.
Warte mal, ich mach mir das mal auf.
Check my solution. Bam.
Next.
Und das wollen wir jetzt als nächstes machen.
Warte mal, ich mach mir das mal für morgen schon auf.
Wo hat's denn das gepostet?
Ja, ne.
Warum würde man sowas machen mit Super...
Also Supervisor D
kenne ich nur
historisch,
als man das noch
in Container eingebaut hat, beziehungsweise
heute auch noch, ja, also wenn du in Containern
quasi sowas haben willst,
wie, du brauchst ja bei Containern immer
einen Einstiegsprozess, ja, du kannst ja bei
Containern immer nur einen Prozess starten. Und wenn du
quasi in einem Container mehrere Sachen laufen
lassen willst, dann war Supervisor D
früher so angesagt.
Keine Ahnung, ob das immer noch so ist.
Gucken wir mal auf GitHub wieder die...
Ich sehe nicht mehr so wirklich...
Traction da in der Entwicklung.
Ansonsten weiß ich auch nicht, wozu das gut sein soll.
Also wenn man schon sowas haben will und mit so Config, dann kann man auch gleich SystemD nehmen, wenn es halt auf dem System direkt läuft.
ok nächste aufgabe how much do you press text pro chat der meint euch
also wir haben einen task bekommen
dieses Pfeil hier zu komprimieren.
Das Pfeil ist 35.147 Bytes groß.
Und wir sollen es komprimieren.
Kleiner als 9400 Bytes.
You can use any compression tool.
Wir können auch das Pfeil modifieren.
Okay, da bin ich aber gespannt.
Wir stellen einfach mal die Compression Rate hoch.
Docker Init habe ich noch nie gehört.
Was macht
Docker minus init
Oder wie
Schreibt man das einfach nur
Docker init
Ach ne Moment das ist um ein neues Docker Projekt anzulegen
Das ist wieder was anderes
Das meinst du aber wahrscheinlich nicht
Ich denke auch
Wir probieren es einfach
Wir zippen mit minus 9
Und gucken mal was rauskommt
Names
Ja, Server, AWS please
Docker-Image?
Was?
Was gibt's?
Du meinst, du meinst
Docker-Run, oder?
Ach hier,
minus minus init, tatsächlich.
Run an init inside the container
that forward signals...
Aha, was Docker nicht alles hat.
Yes.
So, wir haben hier eine Datei,
names, oder hier, names,
mit
4945 Namen
drin.
So,
editieren.
Bringt nix.
Gucken wir mal die Größe uns an.
35k.
So.
Wir machen das mal, okay,
ich kopiere mir das Ding jetzt einfach
mal.
Bevor ich es irgendwie kaputt mache, okay.
So, Zip. Wir machen mal das einfachste
überhaupt? Names.
Achso.
Geht's?
Machen wir mal minus 9, glaube ich.
Und jetzt Names.
Okay.
16k.
Okay. Das ist es
schon mal nicht.
Ist rar drauf? Ne.
Also das ist es schon mal nicht.
Unzip.
Names.
Also Geht's?
Geht's? Ist es schon mal nicht.
Wisst ihr, was sein könnte?
Dass es für Namen
eine extra Option gibt.
So die 50.000
bekanntesten Namen kann man besser
komprimieren. Mit irgendeiner Option
vielleicht. Also das hat schon mal
nicht funktioniert.
Sevenzip.
Auch nicht.
Ähm.
Ich darf die Datei nicht modifizieren, ne?
You can modify the file without deleting anything in it.
Also ich darf quasi was reinschreiben in das File, aber nichts löschen oder was?
Hä?
Okay, 7-zip haben wir nicht.
Ähm.
LZ, L...
LZ4.
Okay, LZ4 können wir machen.
LZ4 max compression.
Wie benutzt man das Ding?
Z.
LZ4
minus Z
Names.
Okay, das ist noch größer.
Kann ich das sortieren?
Warte mal, ich sorte das mal.
Ah.
Das ist vielleicht schon mal eine...
Ist das vielleicht deutlich kleiner,
wenn es sortet ist?
Geht's, Zip?
Minus 9.
Names sorted.
Ha!
Hat nicht gereicht.
Aber wie...
Es ist closer.
Ja?
Okay.
Es ist sorted.
Können wir es vielleicht
sort names
numeric?
Was irgendwie wenig Sinn macht, aber...
Hm.
What's...
Okay.
What's better than Gzip-9?
Rzip.
Was zum Teufel ist Rzip?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ist auch nicht drauf.
Also generell hab ich bisher nur LZ...
Oder XZ haben wir ja auch noch, oder?
XZ.
Names.
Sorted.
Haha.
Wir haben es.
Okay.
Move. Names. Sorted.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob wir es noch kleiner kriegen?
Ups.
Jetzt habe ich das Ganze gelöscht.
Ja.
Wir gucken jetzt mal.
Gerade wenn wir sagen,
gibt es was minus 9?
Ist das ein Ding?
So?
Das braucht zu viel.
Wir haben nicht so viel RAM.
Was zum...
Hä?
Wir müssten doch eigentlich...
Wir müssten doch genug RAM haben, oder?
Okay, 8.
8 geht. Sehr gut.
Okay, 15.
Und jetzt...
Sorted.
Okay, na wirklich viel kleiner.
Wirklich viel kleiner ist es nicht.
Also, wohin müssen wir das kopieren?
Nach...
Solution.
Sornames.
.xz soll das dann heißen.
Der hat sich hier vertippt.
Home User Admin.
Solution.
Okay.
So.
Und jetzt können wir das Checkscript ausführen und gucken, ob es funktioniert hat.
Okay.
Hat funktioniert.
wird die datei kleiner wenn man das charset von utf 8 auf ascii umstellen
kleiner wird die wahrscheinlich nicht weil es ist in utf 8 enthalten also die ersten keine ahnung
128 Bytes in UTF-8
ist das gleiche wie ASCII.
So, aber wir haben es geschafft.
Easy. Zack. Check.
Korrekt.
Yes.
Excellent, excellent.
Gleich noch was trinken.
Okay, Chat.
Dann lass uns mal gucken.
Ich habe jetzt die gemacht, die ihr wolltet.
Hat noch irgendwie eine
einen Szenario-Wunsch.
Mir egal welches.
Ihr könnt euch...
Wir können auch mal ein schweres machen.
Wollen wir ein schweres machen?
Da werde ich richtig abgefuckt sein wahrscheinlich,
weil man da wieder Zertifikate von Hand ausstellen muss
und Jammer-Files von Hand editieren.
Acht.
Pull a Rapid from a Head.
Okay, machen wir 8.
Rapid MQ Cluster.
Mon KS.
Darf ich mal sagen, dass ich von Rapid MQ
auch keine Ahnung habe?
Außer, dass ich schon ein paar Mal Rapid MQ
restartet habe, habe ich mit Rapid MQ noch nie was
gemacht.
Okay, 10.
Was ist 10?
Database Migration Hell. Oh, nee.
Da mache ich lieber RabbitMQ.
Also, was haben wir?
Leute, das ist jetzt wirklich schwer.
Also aus der Schwerkategorie.
Und das macht es auch mal extra schwer,
weil ich von RabbitMQ keine Ahnung habe.
There is RabbitMQ.
Cluster defined.
Okay, wir haben Docker Compose.
Die haben wir im File.
Bring the system up and then run producer PyScript
in such a way that it's able to send messages to RabbitMQ.
Ich muss die Message Hello LWC senden.
The QName has to be the same?
To send a message?
Okay.
Okay, also das funzt nicht.
To test consuming it
Okay
Na da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt
Zeit in BDO
Ey ich hab seit Jahren war ich nicht mehr in BDO eingeloggt
Ich hab auch gar keinen Bock mehr
Ich hätte schon mal Bock
auch wieder so ein richtig geiles Kreisel-Grind-Game.
Aktuell spiele ich ja immer noch nebenbei
ein bisschen Herr der Ringe online, aber das ist halt
ein uraltes Game.
So ein richtig geiles neues Kreisel-Game
wäre geil. Kreisel-Grind-Game. Mal gucken.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie Guild Wars 3 wird.
Dauert aber ja noch.
Hat der Fabian noch
seinen Twitch-Kanal?
Weil der hat sich noch mal
umbenannt, oder?
Der hat sich jetzt so oft umbenannt, dass ich den Channel
gar nicht mehr finde.
Classic WoW.
Wie viel neuen Content,
der das Ganze interessant macht, gibt es denn
bei Classic Plus?
Ach, dauert auch noch.
Okay.
Das ist er.
Das muss ich mal
aufschreiben.
84.
Der Frasier.
So, jetzt sind wir wieder am Start.
Also, wir sind per SSH.
Sind wir nicht eingeloggt per SSH?
SSH, yes.
Also ja, RapidMQ-Cluster.
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung.
Es läuft über Docker Compose anscheinend.
Läuft schon mal nix. Auch gut.
Rapid
MQ-Cluster
Docker Master.
Okay, was ist unter Agent?
Das ist immer da drauf, ne?
Set Agent, check.
Ja, okay.
Also hier
RapidMQ-Cluster
Master.
Das ist so ein Compose-File.
Mit einem HA-Proxy davor.
Alter.
Ein Erlang-Cookie.
Was steht hier in Enf drin?
Guest, Guest.
V-Host ist Slash.
Musters.
Keine Ahnung.
Cluster Entry Point.
Get Host Name.
Wie viel Zeit hat man überhaupt dafür?
Eine Stunde. Okay, gut.
Und jetzt sagt er hier,
Join Cluster, Use...
Ja, ich würde
sagen, wir starten das jetzt einfach mal.
Docker, Compose,
Compose,
Up.
Ach ne, Minus D muss man machen,
dass es im Hintergrund bleibt, oder?
Ah, dann machen wir das doch mal.
Ich kann mich aber einfach nochmal neu einloggen.
Eats.
Also, irgendwie hat er Schmerzen.
Anscheinend.
So, ich kann das hier ausführen.
Should return message send.
Äh, what the fuck?
Okay, das läuft halt einfach gar nicht.
Das läuft halt einfach gar nicht.
rabbit
diesen klaren diesen ganzen krempe also wir haben keine ports weitergeleitet kann das sein weil
unable to connect okay dass das das funkt also hier hier ja ich brech mal ab also hier was
hatte er unable to perform operation on no traffic mq1 most common reason
tagen notice an region unable to connect to port
Okay, da ist irgendwas in dem Compose-File
verkehrt.
Und hier kommt jetzt...
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht. Okay, das ist schon ein Unterschied,
wenn nix lauscht. Also anscheinend
ist das richtig. So, da ist irgendwas
in der... Boah, ey. Leute.
Was macht eigentlich diese hässliche A-Proxy da?
Was hat denn der damit zu tun?
Docker-Compose-Jammel.
Also, wir haben ein RabbitMQ1,
ein RabbitMQ2,
ein RabbitMQ3.
Und ein HA-Proxy.
So, ein HA-Proxy macht 5672.
Ist das der Rebel-MQ-Port?
Wahrscheinlich.
Also 5672, da müssen wir mal in die HA-Proxy-Config reingucken.
Depends on...
Ja, der balanced wahrscheinlich.
Denke ich auch.
Wir gucken mal gerade in den HA-Proxy-Config rein.
HA-Proxy-Config.
Listen.
5, 6, 7, 2.
Hier, Server.
RapidMQ 1, 2, 3.
Ja.
Der Balanced.
Und das hier ist das Management Interface
von dem RapidMQ anscheinend.
1, 5, 6, 7, 2.
Okay, von aus der A-Proxy ist okay.
Join Cluster RabbitMQ1.
RabbitMQ1.
Cluster Entry Point.
Tja, jetzt wäre es halt irgendwie geil, wenn man eine Ahnung von RabbitMQ hätte, ne?
So, dass das Cookie stimmt, rate ich jetzt auch einfach mal.
Cluster Entry Point.
So, ich will noch mal in dieses Python-Ding gleich reingucken.
Get Hosted from Environment Variable.
Warte mal, welche Dateien darf ich, darf ich irgendwelche Dateien editieren?
Nur Consumer und Producer darf ich nicht ändern.
Okay.
Wenn Join Cluster nicht leer ist...
S-Z?
Zero, ne?
Wenn das leer ist...
Join Cluster Host...
Das wird als Environment gesetzt.
Okay.
Wenn das leer ist,
dann geht er
dahin.
Okay, das heißt im Endeffekt,
der 1er, der erste Rabbit MQ läuft hier rein.
Die anderen zwei Rabbit MQs laufen hier rein.
So weit von der Theorie her.
Okay, ab.
Äh, wird der HA-Proxy gar nicht gestartet?
Doch.
Starting Programmer, das ist der Rebel MQ1.
Stopping Rapid Application
on
MQ2?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Warum stoppt er die und dann
klastert er? Ist das normal?
Also der kommt nicht zu seinem Node hin, zu dem anderen.
Dann werden wir das doch mal ausprobieren.
Gehen wir jetzt mal.
Also der meckert ja jetzt rum, dass er nicht zu seinem Kollege kommt.
Okay, wir versuchen uns mal da kurz...
Ich versuche mich mal da rein zu exec'en.
Ich habe auch noch die RapidMQ-Friend.
Okay, und jetzt meckert er hier.
Er meckert.
Unable to perform operation on node.
Please.
Target node is unreachable.
Das werden wir gleich ausprobieren, ob der Target-Node unreachable ist.
Wie kommt denn der auf den Port hier?
4, 4, 3, 6, 9.
Wird das überhaupt, Moment, das muss ich mal nachdenken.
Wird das überhaupt in irgendeiner Art und Weise da weitergeleitet?
Aber das ist intern, ne?
Intern ist das eigentlich kein...
Okay.
Das scheint die Fall zu sein.
Intern ist das ja dann wahrscheinlich kein Problem,
weil die Container untereinander miteinander reden können.
Wir probieren das einfach mal.
Wir starten jetzt...
Wir starten das Stalker Compose nochmal.
Dann sagen wir mal...
Dann exakten wir uns mal rein,
falls das gescheit funktioniert.
In den...
muss mal gucken ob nur der 3er und so neu gestartet wird in denen da execkten wir uns jetzt rein
da sind wir
wir müssen gucken ob der kann der rabbit mq1
Alter
Uptinstall Ping
Uptupdate
Das war bescheuert
Aber glücklicherweise darf ich das im Container
Normalerweise sollte Container gar nicht so gebaut sein
Dass das mit Root und
Aber installier mal Ping
Ist es Ping?
Hier, IP Utils Ping
Gut
Kann der überhaupt...
Nee.
Er kann seinen Rabbit MQ-1 gar nicht...
Meine Güte.
Er kann seinen Rabbit MQ-1 gar nicht ankörlen.
Das ist doch schon mal ein Problem, oder?
Leute, ich habe so lange nichts mit...
Mit...
Mit Dragon Compose gemacht.
Und so lange nichts mit, also noch nie wirklich was mit RabbitMQ.
Also der kommt da schon mal nicht hin.
Die Namensauflösung findest du nicht.
Das können wir ja schon mal fixen.
So, Docker Compose.
Oder hoffe ich mal.
Müssen die im gleichen Network überhaupt hängen?
Vielleicht geht das ja so gar nicht.
Braucht man ein eigenes Network, oder?
Alter, das ist fünf Jahre her, wo ich Docker Compose größere Sachen gemacht habe.
Docker Compose.
Reach one pod from other.
container networking in compose ok ok das geht dass das geht angeblich
okay wir müssen wir müssen keinen
Okay.
Also die Namensauflösung funktioniert nicht.
Oder habe ich mich verschrieben?
Depends on RapidMQ1?
Depends on RapidMQ1.
Set.
Maus.
RabbitMQ1.
Also daran liegt es zumindest schon einmal.
Zum Teil.
Dass das nicht funktioniert.
Ausnehmen.
RabbitMQ1.
Okay, ich werde den Kram gerade nochmal starten.
Und mich dann nochmal execken.
Docker, PS.
Ich execke mich hier nochmal auf den...
Achso, welcher ist denn überhaupt welcher?
WMQ 2.
Hä?
Chat?
Monkass?
Achso, weil ich vorhin installiert hab
Ah
Was ist denn das
Der ist erst da
Und dann
Und dann wird er gestoppt
Der kackt ab
Der RabbitMQ1
Kackt ab
Cannot open
Log RabbitMQ Log
For reading no such file or directory
Der kackt ab
Das ist das Problem
Also eines der Probleme
Der RabbitMQ1 kackt ab
Dann müssen wir mal schauen
Warum der RabbitMQ1 abkackt
Auf jetzt mach mal hin mit dem BN
Ne der hat Klimaanlage
Kein Problem
Also am Cluster Entry Point
Der meckert ja, dass er irgendwelche Sachen
Nicht zugreifen kann
Also die Logs nicht zugreifen kann
Der meckert, dass es
Warnlog RabbitMQ
Log nicht gibt
Naja, ich mein wir können
Also was wir machen können ist
mkdir-p
Mal so probieren.
Docker-Compose ab.
Jetzt bin ich aber gespannt,
ob der wieder abkackt oder nicht.
Ah, das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Chat, das sieht doch schon deutlich besser aus.
Der ist nicht abgekackt.
Doch, wieder. Schon wieder.
Immer wieder.
Ah, der will das tailen.
Tail.
Hä?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wo tailt er das denn?
Ich hab das noch gar nicht.
Gar nicht?
Ich creppe das gleich mal.
Alter, brech ab.
Hopp.
Wie?
Canceled.
Und jetzt?
So, alles weg.
So.
Ähm.
Lass da.
Ist da irgendein Tail drin gewesen?
Ach.
Aber deswegen.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das Problem ist, dass der überhaupt dahin kommt.
der sollte doch vorhin der sollte doch schon der sollte doch hier eigentlich
schon hängen oder was macht der mit mq m m m m q ctl rate was macht das maus
Fragen wir mal.
Was ist das?
Vollständig gestartet und betriebsbereit ist.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Das heißt...
Nur, dass ich das mal richtig sehe.
Das ist aber...
Das sollte dann wahrscheinlich nicht so sein.
Also, der startet den hier im Hintergrund.
docker-entrypoint.sh
Ist das dann?
Wo ist denn das?
docker-entrypoint.sh
Muss ich mal gucken, was das macht.
Naja, zumindest RabbitMQ-Server.
Dann wartet er.
Und dann kommt er hier unten hin.
Dann kommt er hier unten hin.
Das gibt es nicht.
Also ich meine, was wir natürlich noch machen könnten ist,
einfach nur mal zu gucken,
Touch.
Barlock, RabbitMQ,
Blub.Lock.
So.
Oder mal so.
Echo 1.
Einfach mal gucken, ob das was bringt.
So, wir machen jetzt mal,
wir gucken jetzt mal in
Docker PS.
Gucken wir mal in den da rein.
Ah, das ist der 3er.
In den da rein.
Das ist der 1er.
War, Lock, Rabbit, MQ, Plup, Punkt, Lock.
Okay, das...
Okay, hier.
Jetzt ist er nicht abgekackt.
Das Cannot Open...
Der crasht irgendwie.
Nee, das ist jetzt RabbitMQ2.
RabbitMQ, die...
Die haben irgendwie keinen Log-File.
Das ist schon mal sehr merkwürdig irgendwie.
Vielleicht ist der Pfad falsch, ja.
Wo lockt...
Wir gucken mal hier. Wir sind jetzt ja hier auf dem Einser.
Wir gucken mal, wo der...
Wo der hinlockt.
Also es gibt einen Rabbit MQ.
Na gut, es gibt ein RabbitMQ, aber es gibt...
Also der Ordner stimmt, aber der lockt nicht.
Wir können mal der Gelegenheit gerade mal gucken.
Was ist denn in dem...
Haben wir da sowas wie ein RabbitMQ-Conf oder sowas drin?
Ne, haben wir nicht.
Bar, Log,
Rabbit, äh, ne.
ETC,
Upt, Install, Wim.
Erstmal, bam. So.
Upt, Update.
Benzile, jetzt erstmal ein Wim.
rabbitmq default log
log file
the base directory contains
aha, aha, aha
Was ist denn das Default?
Was ist das Default?
Ich meine, ich hätte auch gesagt, Warlock RabbitMQ.
Warlock RabbitMQ, okay.
Ja, gut.
Statt GPT labert sich wieder was zusammen.
AbitMQ Diagnostics.
Was es hier alles gibt.
WTF?
Steht das da drin?
Ich sehe da kein Logverzeichnis.
Kann das sein, dass die Slinger einfach kein Log schreiben?
Log-File-Standard-Out.
Ja gut.
Das erklärt natürlich das Problem.
ETC.
Rabbit MQ.
Conf D.
Log Console. Okay.
Der Log nur Standard Out.
Ich weiß jetzt, mir kommt es halt
so vor, als wäre das ein Bug
von der Aufgabe, aber wahrscheinlich
ist es Absicht und ich soll das
checken, dass das so ist.
So, also.
Dann Cluster Entry Point.
Dann machen wir das einfach so.
Bam.
So, easy.
Ich will so wenig wie möglich von dem, was vorhin noch drin ist, editieren.
So, also jetzt kann er überall loggen.
Das heißt, es sollte jetzt zumindest nicht mehr abkacken beim Starten.
Die Containers.
Schauen wir mal.
Guck, da steht auch nichts von Locked.
Endvariable.
Outdated, overrated, she baited.
Warum stoppt er die denn?
So.
Okay.
RabbitMQ läuft.
Es läuft jetzt zum ersten Mal.
Haben wir das?
Python.
Okay, wir haben eine Fehlermeldung.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Q must be a string or unicode string, but got none.
Okay
Producer
Producer darf ich nicht
Okay, Guest, Guest, Port
RMQQ muss ich setzen
Das muss ich setzen
Und wie ich die Q nenne
Ist dann egal oder was?
RMQ.
Okay.
Export gleich
Blub.
Machen wir jetzt einfach mal so.
Message sent to RabbitMQ.
Test consuming it
Consumer
Oh
Monka
Access refused
Login was refused
Using authentication
Authentication mechanism
Plain
Plain login refused
Invalid credentials
Ja, Moment
Ist es jetzt
Ist das jetzt refused?
Ne, es ist refused, weil die
Logfiles
bestimmt nicht schlimm
konsumen.
Ah, hier. Username, Passwort.
Da muss ich das noch ändern.
Username, Passwort wollen wir haben.
Das muss hier noch rein.
In das Compose-File.
Wie viel Zeit haben wir eigentlich noch?
31 Minuten.
Yitz.
auf abbrechen hier ob das machen da nicht docker compose
mq default user mq
Äh
Chat, ich bin verwirrt
Wo kommt diese Environment Variable her
In einem Compose File
Aus meiner Shell, wo ich das Compose aufrufe
Oder wo kommt das her?
Warte mal, da war doch ein End-File, ne?
Guest, guest
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment
Das muss ich wahrscheinlich
Muss ich das sourcen, oder?
Oder source das Docker für einen?
Ich hab keinen Blastenschimmer
Aber wir editieren das jetzt einfach mal
es ist...
Was? Ich darf das nicht changen?
Ich darf das End-File nicht changen?
Habe ich
Root-Rechte?
Natürlich nicht!
Okay, weißt du was?
Das darf ich auch nicht changen.
Ich hab da überall keine Rechte drauf.
Vorsicht.
Okay.
Geht das so?
Wenn ich das so setze, checkt es dann das?
Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith Faith
Okay.
Invalid Credentials.
Das find ich schon mal nicht.
Okay, wie...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wie sagt man dem dummen Docker-Compose jetzt?
Also Rechte
Also ich hab keine
Edit-Rechte auf das End-File
Das suckt
Ah, ich weiß, was ich machen kann
Ich kann das hier reinschreiben
Docker Compose
Genau, RabbitMQDefaultUser
Das setzt er hier
Aber
Ich kann einfach
Hoffe ich mal
Ich hoffe mal, dass ich das
Dass ich das überschreiben kann
Export
export und wir sind ordentlichen drücken das ein und das hier ist jetzt username
password ja und keine ahnung slash oder so war das glaube ich ab das machen wir
und jetzt gucken wir gleich,
jetzt loggen wir uns gleich da drauf ein.
Exec.
Locker Master.
Rabbit MQ
1.
Okay.
So
Und jetzt mal
Dieses Diagnostics Ding will ich nochmal ausführen
Wie war das?
Hat sich
Hat sich das jemand
Gemerkt?
Rapid MQ Diagnostics
Ah hier, Chat GPT sagt Status
Okay, gut
Ihr sollt jetzt ja...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Das sieht doch gut aus jetzt, oder?
Username, Passwort.
Schauen wir mal.
Hä?
Was will er denn?
Invalid Credentials.
Warum?
Warum sind die Credentials invalid?
Q, hello, okay.
Login refused.
Username invalid credentials.
Aber es ist doch
Username
Password
Ist doch okay so
Das ist wieder jetzt irgendwas richtig dummes
Ist es denn überhaupt diese Variable
Chat falls ihr mich irgendwo verschrieben habt
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Wie viel Zeit haben wir noch?
Okay, erst 23 Minuten.
Es wird eng.
Also jetzt weiß ich nicht so genau, was
er für Probleme hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Also die Compose-Jammel kann ich ja nicht editieren.
Dieser ganze Mist hier ist
egal, den überschreibe ich eh.
Und zwar hier.
Oder passiert... Moment, Moment, vielleicht überschreibt er die hier.
Ah, nee, nee, nee, nee, das bringt ja nichts, wenn ich die hier setze, ne?
Wahrscheinlich wird das nicht vererbt.
Wie kriege ich den Scheiß denn da rein?
Kann man? Okay, ich hab...
Warte mal, ich kann ja das Compose-File selbst nicht editieren.
Ich kann nur dieses Skript editieren.
User Local Bin.
Da muss ich mal kurz reingucken.
User Local Bin, Docker Entry.
Du meinst, ich soll mir ein eigenes Docker-File anlegen?
Oh, das ist natürlich auch sehr, sehr, sehr clever.
Was steht denn da drin?
Also.
Nix interessantes steht da drinnen.
Aber ich check's nicht.
Guck mal.
RapidMQ Default User.
RapidMQ Default Pass.
Behost.
Kommt es jetzt eigentlich...
Woher kommt es jetzt eigentlich?
Kommt es jetzt...
Kommt es jetzt hierher?
Klopp.
Kommt es jetzt hierher oder woanders?
Oder kommt es jetzt...
0w.
Kommt es hierher?
Ab.
Exekten wir uns mal wieder.
Okay.
Das kommt aus meinen...
aus meinen...
ähm...
Aus dem Endpfeil kommt es nach wie vor.
Jetzt check ich es noch weniger.
Dann ist das doch komplett richtig, was ich hier mache.
Export. Guck mal hier.
Consumer.
So, es muss im Endeffekt
hier Username
Username und Passwort sein.
Und das habe ich ja.
ja username und passwort also also im prinzip genauso wie es sein muss ja
doch dass ihr das hier kann ich mir sparen das brauche ich nicht
das brauche ich nicht
ja username password
was ist ein reppin mqt von muss ich da q oder irgendwie sowas rein schreiben
Was X-Pulse, wo war was doppelt?
Also passt.
Okay, was hat der für Schmerzen?
Stört er sich daran, dass das plain ist?
Oder dass der User nicht stimmt?
Invalid Credentials.
Muss man das irgendwie anders machen? Ist das irgendwie Magic oder...
Wieso? Was ist an den Exports? Echo, Echo, Dollar...
Wie ist das? Rabbit, Rabbit, Rabbit, Rabbit, MQ, Default, Pass, Default, User.
Stimmt doch.
Aber der frisst das ja irgendwie nicht.
Ich kenne mich dafür zu wenig mit RabbitMQ aus, aber wir googeln jetzt mal kurz danach.
Check hier bitte.
Oh, was ist das Problem?
Ja, ja.
RabbitMQ-CTL-List-Users.
Sowas gibt's.
Was denn? Was willst du auf Guest setzen?
Nee, nee.
Guest ist falsch.
Wir dürfen Consumer Pie
nicht editieren.
Exek.
Okay, also.
Jaja.
Der Revenant am Cure ist noch nicht da.
Oh, ist dieser Diagnostics-Ding?
Okay.
Kann ich so mit RabbitMQ
CTL-Users anlegen?
Geht das vielleicht?
Ah.
Ich kann die Compose nicht ändern.
So, wo ist die Datei, die man hier...
ConsumerPile.
Okay.
Äh.
Moin.
Huch, wurde ich geradet?
Ah, dankeschön.
Ich hoffe, alles ist repariert.
Wir versuchen gerade,
Linux-Server zu reparieren.
Das ist so eine...
Falls ihr das hier noch nicht gesehen habt.
Z-Server ist eine Seite,
da gibt es, glaube ich, 80 Szenarios mittlerweile.
Und bei jedem Szenario
kriegt man einen kaputten Linux-Server,
den man fixen muss.
Wir machen gerade ein schweres Szenario
und haben nur noch
13 Minuten Zeit, es zu lösen.
Ihr wisst ja, was ich witzig finde.
Dass er sagt,
Ich verstehe diese Anzeige hier gar nicht.
User, Username.
Ach, der hat keine Rechte.
Der hat keine Rechte.
Also muss ich jetzt was sagen?
Username?
Wie addet man?
Rabbit MQ add
Keine Ahnung
Give user admin rights
Was weiß ich, wie das funktioniert?
Ich hab das noch nie benutzt
Set user tags
Username administrator
Okay, das wollen wir, perfekt
Ich weiß nicht, was das macht
Aber es wird schon funktionieren
Okay, list users
Aha, so
Okay, jetzt
Not allowed, aha
Moment, das ist jetzt wieder ein anderer, neuer Fehler.
Access to V-Host
slash refused for username.
Okay, das könnte sein,
dass das noch nicht angelegt ist.
Das ist ja so eine Message-Queue-Geschichte.
Wir producen mal eine Message.
What?
Was muss ich da exporten?
Oh.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Was war das hier? Was mussten wir setzen?
Ähm.
AMQ mussten wir setzen. Export.
AMQ. Gleich.
Moment.
Wie hieß das?
Consumer Pie.
So, die Q muss Hello heißen.
Hello?
Okay, so jetzt.
Pregge, Leute, Chat, pregge.
Okay, Message sent.
Consumer.
Ah, Alter!
Not allowed.
Access to V-House
slash refused for username.
Okay, wie gebe ich dem
Rechte?
List set permissions.
grant user permissions for specific wie haus ich habe eigentlich gedacht als administrator darf man
alles.
Da brauchen wir nicht
Sudon.
Okay.
Ha! Es geht,
Leute, es geht.
So.
Wo ist der Check, ob es funktioniert?
Was?
Achso, falsche Kiste.
Okay, Leute, wir haben es geschafft.
Alter, was ein Krampf, man.
Check my solution.
Äh.
Ach so, ich weiß, woran es liegt.
Ich muss doch eine Message producen.
Ja.
Die Message habe ich doch eben schon selbst wieder aus der Queue gelesen.
Oh.
Okay, lass uns mal kurz angucken,
was uns geholfen hätte.
Na, also wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal kurz,
was wir hätten machen können,
wenn wir nicht selbst drauf gekommen wären.
Also, starting containers.
ja das haben wir gemacht docker logs schon ist es ja ja genau war log rapid mq lock das
nordex ist haben wir gefunden schreibst du das jetzt es gibt ein github repo wo glaube
ich sogar lösungen drauf stehen mittlerweile die habe ich da habe ich letztens gesehen
Die github set servers ich glaube da gibt es sogar musterlösungen für
Irgendwo
Ach nee gibt es nicht okay
gibt keine musterlösung
Nächster nächster clue fix the entry point
Ist to run any process so the container
Okay, das haben wir nicht so gemacht, aber wir haben was ähnliches gemacht.
Das ging nicht.
Authentication Issue.
Das haben wir auch gemacht.
Hard Coded Values, habe ich auch gesehen, ja.
Export RapidMQ Passwort
Ja
Aber Leute, guckt mal
Das, das, ähm
Das hat bei mir nicht funktioniert
Wir mussten uns rein exec'en
Also wir haben das, wir haben den
Die Solution sieht bei uns komplett anders aus
Wir haben uns rein exakt in den RabbitMQ, also ich meine, schöner ist das natürlich, wenn es funktioniert.
Wir haben uns rein exakt in den Container und haben dann mit Rabbit, wie heißt das Ding, RabbitCTL oder so, die User angelegt.
Oder wir können alle Authentifizierung entfernen.
Okay, nice.
So, Chat.
Jetzt, weil so viele neue Leute da sind.
Wir haben jetzt die Lösung hier...
...gecheckt, funzt alles.
Also, ich zeige euch das nochmal kurz.
Hat man denn soweit verstanden?
Jetzt mal eine Frage an die, die neu dabei sind.
Hat man verstanden, um was es geht?
Oder soll ich es nochmal kurz erklären?
Ich kann das beispielsweise mal hier am ersten Easy-Szenario erklären.
Also, Set-Servers ist eine Seite.
da ist irgendwie 87 Szenarien drauf.
Bei jedem Szenario kriegst du einen echten Linux-Server.
Also du kriegst jetzt nicht irgendwie so eine simulierte Umgebung oder sowas.
Du kriegst einen echten Linux-Server.
Ich glaube bei AWS läuft das.
Und dieser Linux-Server hat einen Fehler.
So, und der Fehler ist hier beschrieben.
Der Fehler ist hier beschrieben.
und wenn man das, ich führ das jetzt nochmal aus,
der Fehler ist hier beschrieben,
zum Beispiel, es gibt hier eine Logdatei,
da wird Zeug reingeschrieben und wir sollen
gucken, welcher Prozess in die Logdatei schreibt
und den Prozess killen.
Genau.
So, und
es dauert ein bisschen, weil wie gesagt,
da wird eine echte VM gestartet im Hintergrund.
Dann soll man das fixen,
man hat eine gewisse Zeitspanne Zeit,
wenn man länger braucht, wird das Server automatisch runtergefahren.
und am Ende gibt es einen Knopf, um zu überprüfen, ob man es richtig gemacht hat.
Falls man gar nicht drauf kommt, gibt es auch bei den meisten Übungen so einen Knopf für Hinweise.
So, und wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr euch jetzt das nächste Szenario,
nachdem ich euch das jetzt nochmal einmal gezeigt habe, könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
Was wir als nächstes machen wollen.
Und wer Prime-Sub ist, darf auch ein Szenario, das ihn interessiert, doppelt vorschlagen.
Also sprich, ihr könnt dann auch ein Szenario vorschlagen, was wir schon gemacht haben, falls es euch interessiert.
Aber ein bisschen Setout muss sein.
Doppelte Szenarien mache ich nur für Prime-Subs.
Ansonsten müsst ihr ins Wort gucken.
Aber ihr könnt euch jedes Szenario aussuchen
Was wir noch nicht erledigt haben
Auch ohne Prime Sub
Aber nur ein Szenario doppelt machen will ich eigentlich nicht
Das mach ich dann nur für Prime Sub
So, guck jetzt kriegt man hier einen Server
Kriegt man eine IP
Wo man sich einloggen kann
Machen wir hier den ganzen Kram von eben zu
ssh.zack
So, jetzt sind wir
bei Amazon, bei AWS auf dem Linux-Server
drauf und jetzt müssen wir uns hier
die Aufgabe angucken. Aha, es gibt hier
eine Log-Datei, wo
Sachen reingeschrieben werden,
wie man hier sieht.
Und wir sollen jetzt rausfinden, welcher
Prozess
darauf zuschreibt,
darauf reinschreibt und den Prozess bäten.
Gucken wir mit lsoff auf die Datei,
killen den Prozess,
Gucken, ob noch was reingeschrieben wird.
Wird nichts mehr reingeschrieben.
Dann können wir sagen, guck mal, ob das stimmt, was ich gemacht habe.
Ja, stimmt.
Also so funktioniert die Seite.
Du würdest gern die 10 sehen.
Fun mit Mr. Jason?
Oder welche 10 meinst du?
Die 10 oder die 10?
Database Migration from Hell.
Oh.
Komm, wir machen...
Wir haben jetzt eine schwere Aufgabe gerade...
Hat er die überhaupt abgehakt, dass wir die gemacht haben, Chat?
Moment, Moment.
Hat er die abgehakt?
Ja, hat er.
Hat er.
Part 17.
Ulama Troubles.
Wollen wir nicht...
Wollen wir nicht mal was...
Wollen wir was mittelschweres?
Komm, Chat.
Chat, wir machen mal was mittelschweres.
Wir haben jetzt...
Wir haben jetzt 40 Minuten oder so an einer schweren Aufgabe gesessen.
Wir machen jetzt mal was Einfaches, okay?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das war, okay.
Okay, wenn...
Okay.
Wir machen das jetzt so.
Wir machen jetzt eine mittlere Aufgabe.
Okay?
Und wenn wir es schaffen,
in der mittleren Aufgabe
sagen wir,
7 Prime Subs zu bekommen.
Weil ich hab keinen Bock, die zu machen.
Dann mach ich noch hinterher
Database Migration from Hell.
Aber vorher,
ich muss mich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen ausruhen.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal eine mittlere Aufgabe, okay?
Weil eigentlich
hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock auf
Database Migration from Hell.
Also 25 hättest du gerne.
25.
XZLZMA
Library Compromised.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Okay, sag mal 5 Prime Subs.
Ne, 7.
7.
Ich hab...
5 packen wir wahrscheinlich.
7.
Jetzt sind es noch 6.
Okay.
Chat, ihr müsst mitzählen, dass ich nicht vergesse gleich.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Kanister-Koppel.
Mr. Harry Potter,
Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Oh ne, ich hätt's höher setzen sollen,
Alter, ich hätt's höher setzen sollen.
Wir machen jetzt eh erstmal die Aufgabe.
Also die machen wir auf jeden Fall noch.
Und danach machen wir, wenn wir's packen,
Database Migration from Hell.
Wenn wir's in der Zeit erreichen.
Also ihr könnt jetzt hoffen,
dass ich mich richtig dumm anstelle
und wir eine Weile brauchen.
Und dann haben wir noch eine Weile Zeit für Prime Subs.
Dankeschön, Coffee Caster.
Ich muss so Sachen öfters machen, oder?
Das ist eigentlich der krasseste Sellout ever.
Da kann ich mir auch
Ukraine und Seagate Sellouts sparen.
Muss einfach mehr Prime Sub
Sellouts machen.
Vielleicht sollte ich
Chat, Chat, vielleicht sollte ich
morgen, am Sonntag
bei 50 Prime Sub
ein neues YouTube Video.
Einfach mal ein bisschen baiten, Alter.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, was, was und wie lang.
Okay, jetzt auf, Server, erstell dich mal.
Gut, Patrick, du hast mitgezählt, ne?
Fünf, fünf, fünf noch.
Vier noch, vier noch.
Also, danke schön, Leute, für die Subs.
Exzellente Subscriptions hier, das ist sehr...
Also.
Also, was ist das Problem auf dem Server?
Wir loggen uns jetzt erstmal ein.
So. Yes.
Also, das Problem ist,
dass so viel Text...
Komm.
Ich hab keinen Bock, wieder on the fly zu übersetzen.
Das ist so viel.
Also.
Ja, ich bin human.
Wobei bin ich mir manchmal selbst nicht so ganz sicher.
Also.
Die Linux Shared Library
Lib Z. Aber das ist tatsächlich
ein echtes Problem gewesen.
Das war vor einer Zeit. Das war vor.
Wann war denn dieser XZ?
Vor einem Jahr oder so?
Wann war das mit XZ?
Das ist ein Jahr her.
Da gab es richtig, richtig Probleme.
Also das ist tatsächlich ein realistisches,
realistisches Beispiel hier.
Also, liblzma wurde kompromittiert. Für dieses Beispiel verwenden sie anscheinend nicht die wirklich anfällige Datei, sondern tun nur so als ob.
Die Datei... Alter, was? Alter, oh, WTF? Was zum Teufel macht hier...
Also.
Unter dem Pfad ist die unverfälschte Version.
Betrachten Sie dieselbe Bibliothek an anderen Pfaden.
Ich kann mir das auf Deutsch nicht durchlesen.
Das ist mir zu dumm.
also die library es bin kompromiss sie benutzt natürlich nicht die echte kompromisse library
sondern so ne fake so unter user lib bla bla bla bla 525 ist die ist die ohne fehler
So, wenn diese Datei noch woanders liegt, nicht unterhalb von dem Pfad hier, dann soll ich davon ausgehen, dass die kompromittiert ist oder halt anfällig.
Oder halt von irgendeinem Angreifer da platziert.
find all instances of this malicious l7l lippel zmr library remember it's the same library but
in different directory locations and make it so one of the running processes use it
by the application web app and job app still run properly ok also das hier ist der test
LSOFGREP
LZReturnsOnlyThePathTo
Okay, easy, können wir machen.
Also,
jede Menge
kompromittierte Libraries am Start.
OptTrash
Moment,
sehe ich das richtig?
Das läuft überhaupt nicht mehr?
Also,
Also, Web-App und Job-App laufen überhaupt nicht.
Okay, muss ich mal root werden.
System CTL.
Status.
Wie heißt das Ding? Web-App und Job-App.
Web-App.
Job-App.
Die laufen?
Warum sehe ich die denn dann nicht, wenn die laufen?
Achso, ja doch.
Vielleicht laufen die ja und...
Achso, weil ich nicht root war.
Haha.
Ja, das sieht schon besser aus.
Okay, keines der...
Okay, keines der Programme verwendet die.
Docker...
Wie, TF, was ist denn hier noch alles am Laufen?
Friedrich Merz.
Friedrich 69 Merz.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, jetzt sind wir bei drei Subs, oder?
Oder vier?
Drei noch.
Oh nein.
Okay, Opt, Trash, Lib, LZM A5.
Also das ist anscheinend mal die kompromittierte Library.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Nichts.
Wir gucken mal System, System, D, System und dann hier Web App.
Gucken wir uns mal die Web App Service.
Ist da auch der Job App?
Der Job App ist da auch.
Also wir gucken uns mal den Service an.
Hier, LD Library Path.
Opt Trash.
Tech Wait.
Job App.
Also normalerweise, nur mal so zur Erklärung.
Normalerweise ist es so, dass Linux hat so eine Standard-Reihenfolge, wo es Libraries sucht.
Wenn du ein Programm startest und dann klappert das so ein paar Standardpfade ab, wo Libraries liegen.
Und falls du eine Library benutzen möchtest, die nicht in einem dieser Standardpfade liegt,
also ich muss das anders sagen, ja, also du startest ein Programm und dieses Programm braucht die Library, blubb.
Dann sucht Linux quasi so Shared Object, sucht die Library in verschiedenen Pfaden
und wenn es die nicht findet, dann geht es halt mit.
Du kannst allerdings Linux sagen
Ey, guck mal
Schau doch mal
Auch hier nach
Ob Trash ist
Relativ
Obviously
Kein normaler Pfad, wo er normalerweise sucht
Also das können wir schon mal rausschmeißen
Das können wir rausschmeißen
Und
Job-App kann man rausschmeißen.
Was ist bei der Gelegenheit?
Gucken wir gerade mal, was denn hier eigentlich drin steht.
Was uns der Angreifer da noch so hingelegt hat.
Okay.
Zeug.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich das einfach rausschmeißen kann.
Sondern wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich brauche ich irgendwas von den anderen da.
Aber wir machen jetzt erstmal einen Restart.
Restart von der Web-App.
Übrigens, Leute, jetzt mal realistisch betrachtet.
Die einzig korrekte Antwort da drauf ist, wenn ihr einen Server habt, wo so viele Dinger drauf getrieben wurden,
das Ding neu aufbauen.
Und nicht von Hand fixen.
Ihr müsst davon ausgehen, es ist alles kompromittiert, was auf diesem Server drauf ist.
Was?
Warning.
Ja, ja, stimmt. Sollte ich vielleicht machen.
Okay, die läuft wieder.
Oh, die Musik ist aus.
Äh, nicht Stats, Status.
Status.
Okay, Web App läuft.
Werden wir mal ob jetzt die webapp da drin ist
Aber die werbe läuft
Wir müssen den ganzen Krempel erstmal beenden hier.
Also alles, was hier läuft,
alles, was hier gestartet ist, kann weg.
Ja.
Das ist auch schon mal verdächtig, dass das trotzdem wieder geladen wird.
Also, es kann alles weg.
Dann würde ich sagen,
ich weiß nicht, ob es da eine elegantere Variante gibt,
aber
wir skripten uns jetzt mal was.
Nämlich,
wir killen
alle Pits.
Oh shit, Leute.
Sehe ich das richtig? Sogar unser System D
benutzt das falsche Ding.
Wait a minute.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind am Arsch.
Okay, ich kill trotzdem mal alles
Also vielleicht, okay
System D
Kann man System D überhaupt killen?
Geht das?
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, ehrlich gesagt
Was passiert, wenn ich sage
Kill minus 9, 1
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert
Geht das?
Nee, das geht anscheinend nicht.
Also als erstes werden wir mal diesen Kram hier löschen.
Okay, wir killen erstmal.
Wir killen erstmal alles, was es hier gibt.
Rep.
So.
Cut.
Minus D.
Leerzeichen minus f1 mit f2 f3 an dem moment abk abk abk besser abk
Print dollar 1 so dollar 2 ok jetzt haben wir die pits
Jetzt sagen wir xa kill
Jetzt habe ich auch mein ssh gekillt so als keine so schlaue idee max
Ich hab SSH und SSH
Okay, das war ne blöde Idee
Das war keine so schlaue Idee
Geht das hier, wenn ich hier starte
Okay, okay, okay
Wir machen das nochmal
Was für ein Szenario war das jetzt?
Das war jetzt keine so schlaue Idee, Run.
Eher 0.1 Engineer, oder?
Okay, mein SSH abzuschießen war jetzt nicht so schlau, das gebe ich zu.
Aber ich muss, ich muss ja alles mal beenden.
Sonst sagt es doch richtig.
Was?
Ich glaube, du hast was verpasst.
Nee, du hast nichts verpasst.
Okay.
Okay, SSH nehmen wir aus der Liste erstmal.
Aber SSH müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch restarten.
Auf, Server, mach hin.
So, jetzt. Das ist natürlich eine neue IP.
Yes.
Okay.
Also, dann machen wir mal was anderes.
Was ist denn hier für...
Was sind denn hier für Prozesse drin,
die ich nicht abschießen will?
Äh, SSHD
will ich nicht abschießen.
Ah, eigentlich nur SSHD, oder?
Also sagen wir jetzt hier einfach mir
Minus V
SSHD machen wir noch rein.
Das wird mich jetzt zwar ausloggen,
aber ich müsste mich eigentlich wieder einloggen können.
Okay, nice.
Hat schon etwas besser funktioniert.
Gut, es läuft ein bisschen weniger jetzt.
So, SSH logge ich mich nochmal aus.
Nochmal neu ein.
Fuck, hab ich mit dem Scheiß schon wieder den Server kaputt gemacht?
Hahaha, shit.
Och, komm.
Einmal mit Profis, Leute.
Einmal mit Profis. Ich hab den Server schon wieder kaputt gemacht.
Ich muss erstmal fixen
Ja, aber ich wollte erstmal einschränken
Nach was ich überhaupt gucken muss
Man sollte halt da nicht alles killen
Okay, noch mal
Okay, jetzt aber
Jetzt aber, Chat
Einfach Simling
Das bringt aber halt bei den Geladenen nix, ne?
Das hat ja quasi eine Copy davon.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall den Kram abschießen irgendwie.
Ja, dann machen wir es halt händisch.
Aber erstmal müssen wir auf jeden Fall fixen.
Weil, was auch schon äußerst merkwürdig war, ist, dass die, der Web-App und sowas, die Web-App und die Job-App, dass die irgendwie wieder die alte geladen haben.
Vielleicht gibt es ja noch irgendwie so eine globale, globale Linker-Config oder sowas.
Kann man Need Restart installieren?
Du kannst was installieren.
Need Restart kenne ich nicht. Gibt es das?
Gibt es das als Command?
Ach doch, das kenne ich.
Das ist das, was beim Raspberry Pi immer nervt.
Wo beim Raspberry Pi immer kommt,
Docker hat sich geupdatet,
willst du restarten oder sowas?
ETC, LD, CONF.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Hätte ich jetzt auch vermutet.
Leute, das dürft ihr meinem Chef auf gar keinen Fall zeigen, den Stream heute.
Da muss ich demnächst in die Personalabteilung und nur noch BWL-Sachen machen.
Oder noch schlimmer, Buchhaltung.
Oder noch schlimmer, End-User-Support.
Leute, wenn mein Chef das heute sieht, wie ich den verkackt habe, diesen Server,
dann muss ich demnächst End-User-Support Windows.
Windows End-User-Support machen, ey.
Warum es mal wieder rockelt?
Ja, wie man das Buch gehobelt wird, fallen Späne, ne?
Okay, also mal weiter.
ETC, LD, LD, SO-Konf.
ETC?
Ich wusste bis heute nicht mal, dass dieses Verzeichnis überhaupt existiert, Leute.
Okay, nee, das ist anscheinend okay.
Das scheint alles in Ordnung zu sein.
Also, was mich...
Also, das ist zwar eine mittlere Aufgabe,
aber damit habe ich mich noch nie großartig beschäftigt.
Was ich sehr merkwürdig finde, ist...
Guckt mal.
System CTL.
Sag mal Stopp und jetzt Web App.
Ne?
So, und wenn ich jetzt nochmal greppe, hoffe ich, dass die Web App weg ist.
Nee, ist sie nicht.
Moment, ist jetzt...
75. Okay, doch.
Was ich merkwürdig finde, ist,
dass obwohl es neu gestartet wurde,
dass immer noch diesen Krempel hier verwendet.
Gucken wir mal.
MD5 Sum.
Und die Originaldatei ist...
Die da.
Äh.
Was?
Moment, ist das ein Link oder so?
Äh
Chat
Warum ist das die gleiche Datei?
Sollten die nicht unterschiedlich sein?
Oder ist das jetzt für das Beispiel egal?
also nach ob trash sollte gar nichts linken und das ist auch kein link also
ich finde es merkwürdig dass die 1 5 sommer gleiches ok ok ok so schreiben es ja auch hier
so schreiben es auch hier das haben ja die gleiche hat die gleiche checksumme
Okay, jetzt machen wir mal was anderes.
ETC in den...
Ach eben.
In welchem Jahrtausend lebe ich denn jetzt?
ETC, äh, Stopp, Docker.
Pill all.
Docker D.
Okay.
Äh, welcher Docker ist denn jetzt...
Ist der jetzt noch da?
Hier, der wird wieder gestartet.
Auch damit. Warum?
Was? Wie?
Airflex, danke schön für den...
Oder Reflex.
Danke schön für den Sub. Exzellente Subscription.
Warum greift das immer noch?
Selbst wenn ich das restarte.
Und vor allem...
System CTL Stop Docker.
Okay.
Ist es jetzt weg?
Ja.
Start.
Da muss es irgendwo ein globales Setting geben.
Okay, wir müssen mal creppen
Trash
ETC, Crap, Trash
Okay
Ach, guck mal da
Haha
Ach, guck mal da.
Ja, das ist kein Wunder.
Ich wusste, also wie gesagt, ich wusste bis heute gar nicht, dass es diesen Pfad überhaupt gibt.
Okay, ich gehe mal davon aus, ganz ehrlich, dass man das ohne Probleme löschen kann.
So.
Stopp.
Jetzt restarten wir Docker mal.
Ah, das sieht doch schon deutlich besser aus, Leute.
Das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Also, warum das nicht mehr greifen sollte?
Weil ich nicht wusste, dass es so ein Default-Setting gibt.
So, das ist doch schon mal gut.
Das gefällt mir doch.
Dann logge ich mich jetzt nochmal aus und wieder ein.
Das heißt, wir haben nochmal ein bisschen weniger.
Guck, das ganze SSH-Zeug, Bromtail.
Das können wir einfach auch restarten.
Asuslog.
Asuslog können wir restarten.
So, was haben wir sonst noch?
Das können wir killen
SSHD, okay
Das wird jetzt eklig, ich muss SSHD neu starten
By the way, warum läuft der SSHD überhaupt als Admin?
Moment, wir haben mehrere
SSHDs laufen.
Moment.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht,
dass es, weil ich eingeloggt bin... Ne, passt schon.
Passt schon. Wir haben nur den hier
als Root laufen. Alles andere hat mich auch echt
ein bisschen...
ein bisschen verwirrt.
Den müssen wir jetzt neu starten.
Traue ich mich jetzt? Leute, traue ich mich jetzt SSHD...
Systemctl restart sshd
Bam
Okay
Grab
Und sshd ist immer noch
Hm
Wir haben den Server noch aufgebaut, ja, ja.
Aber ich hatte nie die Standardstelle gefunden.
Alter, was läuft denn hier alles für ein Shit, man?
DHC-Client.
Okay, das können wir noch machen hier.
Restart DHC-Client.
Ne, Moment.
Wenn ich den neu starte, dann...
Dann...
Gibt's da ein Problem?
Keine Ahnung.
gibt irgendwas die h10 oder so daten dann kenne ich kenne jetzt einfach beim ip haben wir ja
auch nicht noch mal ip adressen haben ist overrated outdated so wie ich das ist im
d neu startet da bin ich immer noch ein bisschen ein bisschen unschlüssig ehrlich gesagt gut gotti
können wir neu starten.
Okay.
Container, was auch immer das ist.
Gibt es nicht, hätte mich auch gewundert.
Aber es sieht schon
immer besser aus.
Unattended Updates, das können wir killen.
A-Getty,
was auch immer das ist.
Gibt es anscheinend auch nichts.
Das ist, das ist, das ist, ist das was von AWS?
Ist das was von AWS hier?
Meinst du, ich soll mich trauen?
Ich hab ja Schiss irgendwie, ne?
Dass das dann hängt.
Okay.
Okay, okay, immerhin.
Was zum Teufel? System D, J und U.
Das ist doch irgendein Fake-Ding, oder?
Ah, Login D.
Login D und U-Dev.
What?
Was jetzt?
Hab ich zu lang gebraucht?
Äh.
Schätke?
War das einer von euch?
Oder habe ich es kaputt gemacht?
Ich vermute, das war einer von euch.
Ich vermute, es war einer von euch.
Weil es gibt natürlich einen Trick,
weil das Public ist,
wie man da drankommt.
Machen wir halt nochmal.
Starten wir nochmal neu.
Wir wissen jetzt ja, wo wir gucken müssen.
Wenn das jetzt nochmal passiert, dann...
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr.
Welches war das nochmal?
27? Das da, ne?
Ne.
Doch.
Das da.
Vielleicht war auch die Zeit abgelaufen.
Stimmt.
Ich hab noch Zeit.
Also das ist glaube ich die schwerste Medium-Aufgabe, die wir bis jetzt hatten.
Also in drei Minuten, das ist doch in einer.
Als 10x-Engineer hast du wahrscheinlich mittlerweile schon Neuro-Link vom Elon am Start und machst das einfach in 0,5 Mikrosekunden.
Nein, du darfst die Server nicht rebooten.
Darfst du nicht.
Kein Reboot möglich.
Ich glaube, sobald du rebootest, ist vorbei.
Ups.
Yes.
Also.
ETC, LDSO, CONF.
War das vielleicht mein Re-Exec von System.de, das kaputt gemacht hat?
Wäre das möglich?
Oh, das war doch einer von euch.
Weil es gibt einen Trick, wie man draufkommt.
Auf die Server.
Set Agent.
Was ist eigentlich mit den Punkten?
Äh, meinst du...
du meinst das hier,
meinst du, äh, etc,
äh, ld,
conf, conf.de, meinst du das hier,
mit den Punkten,
also diese conf.de-Geschichte,
das gibt's
an vielen Stellen, ähm,
da kannst du
config-Datei-Snippets normalerweise ablegen,
und
der Prozess liest dann alle
config-dateien in diesem verzeichnis ein das hat nämlich den vorteil du musst
keine system config dateien editieren sondern kannst deine eigenen einfach
dazu legen das ist viel besser für config management tools also kannst du
einfach neue dateien ändern ohne dass du bestehende editieren muss viel besser
dann hast du beim nächsten update nicht das problem dass jam sagt oh die datei
hat sich geändert zwischendurch welche version willst du nehmen das wird dann
quasi alles dazu gepackt in die in die haupt config also wenn es jetzt alles
noch mal neu starten muss
habe ich nicht gerade gestartet
Oh shit, Leute, ich hab die falsche Datei gelöscht, oder?
Ups!
Ähm, vielleicht sollten wir...
Die muss ich löschen.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal gucken...
Was steht denn da so bei mir lokal drin?
Okay
Ich schreib das jetzt einfach mal auch so rein, ja
Faith
x
systemctl
restart
asus
ah ja ok passt
na gut
ähm
ZTL Restart Docker
Oh, hätten wir auch
Ach, ich weiß, Leute, ich weiß
Warum ich eben ausgeloggt wurde
Ich hab doch den DHC-Client
Neu gestartet, ne?
Oder, oder, was auch immer
Neu gestartet
Das wird's wahrscheinlich gewesen sein
Gibt es irgendeine Möglichkeit, alle schon gestarteten Services neu starten zu lassen von SystemD?
Reset all started services.
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Was?
Chat GPT in öffentlich.
Okay, da wäre ich wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie noch drauf gekommen.
Aber das kann man tatsächlich mal machen, das ist keine gute Idee.
das ist eine gute idee
ok schon viel besser
ok jetzt muss ich mich noch mal ausloggen noch mal einloggen
wenn du den reboot ist dann ist er weg ok viel besser bleibt nur noch
Komisches SSHD-Zeug.
Was mich wundert.
Da ist bestimmt was in der Config verkehrt.
Unter DHC-Client
kann ich sowas machen wie
Network
oder so. System CCL Restart Network.
Wenn ich das mache,
fliege ich dann raus.
Okay. YOLO.
Das sieht schon viel besser aus wieder jetzt.
Gut.
System CTL re-exec.
Ne, wie war das? Re...
Re-exec? Ne. Oh Gott.
Demon re-exec. Das war das.
jetzt ist system die system die es selbst okay wir haben alles gefixt bleibt nur noch
die web anwendung übrig
was auch immer das ist
und die zwei web anwendungen bleiben bloß noch übrig stopp web app stopp job app
Okay, jetzt bleibt nur noch das da übrig
Ist das irgendwas für Authentifizierung oder was?
Aha
Also was auch immer das hier ist
Aber ich würde es jetzt einfach mal
killen.
Ups.
In der Hoffnung, es passiert nichts Schlimmes.
Sehr schön.
Wir haben es fast geschafft.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch die Web-Anwendung fixen.
Hier, etc.
Systemd.
Patrick, bei wie viel
Subs sind wir gerade?
Zwei fehlen noch, oder?
Oder drei?
Drei, glaube ich.
Hat jemand mitgezählt?
Zwei noch?
Okay.
Weil ich sehe schon kommen, dass ich
das nicht machen muss.
Weil wir sind hier gleich fertig.
Was ich sehr nice fände.
Wenn ich das nicht machen muss.
Weil wer will schon
Database Migration from Hell sehen?
System?
Web-App.
So, das schmeißen wir raus.
Phoenix Beats.
Wahrscheinlich Phoenix oder so.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Rrrr.
Ja, ja.
Restart.
Yep.
Okay, jetzt bleibt eigentlich nur noch die Job-App.
Job App.
Opt Trash Job App
End File. Ich hab noch ne Idee.
Wir suchen mal was.
Job App End.
Wir suchen das mal. Gibt's das irgendwo?
Ach ne, Opt war das, oder?
Ähm, weil...
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob ich die einfach löschen kann.
Ob das Ding da noch startet?
Wir können es mal ausprobieren.
Wahrscheinlich startet das Ding da nicht.
Restart.
Job-App.
Moment, die geht.
Das geht einfach.
Okay, easy.
Chat, wir haben es geschafft.
Server fixed.
Zählt nur Prime?
Nee, es zählt alles.
Felix, danke schön für den Sub.
Pogu.
Chat, schwere Geburt, aber wir haben es geschafft.
Check my solution.
Bam, korrekt. Easy.
Wir sind bei 0.
Oh, shit.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt wirklich...
Du hast erst gecheckt, als wir bei 0 waren.
Shit.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt wirklich
Database Migration from Hell machen, ja?
60 Minuten?
Extra schwer.
Na geil.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten.
Okay, Florence.
Database migration from hell.
Oh je.
Das wird jetzt was, Chad.
Das wird was.
Also das ist schon ein ekliges Thema,
ohne dass einer
quasi
so ein spießrutenlauf gebaut hat für ein
also wir arbeiten als der vz das stimmt überhaupt nicht wir sind der sec bis wind
in ops engineer enthält aber auch der vz wir arbeiten als der vz engineer einer
company und einem anderen team ist einer abgehauen hat keinen bock mehr auf den
laden gehabt er hat sich quasi gedacht moment ich kann das ich kann das immer
so schlecht anbringen dieses meme hier wo habe ich jetzt finde ich nicht mal
der hat quasi gesagt ist ich also und ist weg und er hat uns eine docker
compose jammer hinterlassen von einem daten von einer datenbank und einer web
anwendung unfinished classic der hat die aufgabe gesehen hat gedacht ich hab es
mich ja ok docker compose und database migration so dazu gibt es noch in engine
x server die quasi reverse proxy vor der applikation und da müssen wir auch den
müssen wir auch fixen mal gucken was der kamil ausgedacht hat
Das wird abfucked.
Das weiß ich jetzt schon. Das wird richtig eklig.
Was?
Anscheinend habe ich das alte nicht beendet.
So.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Das wird so abartig.
Ich hab's schon im Gefühl.
Also das erste, was wir machen,
wir arbeiten uns jetzt da mal von außen nach innen, okay?
Das erste, was wir machen, ist den Nginx-Server fixen.
Wobei, nee, wir fangen mit der Datenbank an.
Wir müssen uns erst mal auf dem System umgucken, keine Ahnung.
Ich muss mir das Docker-Compose-File mal angucken, was da drin steht.
BTF, Leute, ich bin schon 4 Stunden 22 da.
Kommt euch das so lang vor?
Ich hab um 12.30 Uhr ungefähr angefangen.
Kommt mir gar nicht so lang vor.
Aber das freut mich, denn...
Wir haben noch ganz viele Aufgaben offen.
Also können wir noch ein paar Streams mitmachen.
Guck mal, der Server braucht schon so lange aufzubauen.
Das spricht dafür, dass es ein komplexes Szenario ist.
Was richtig abfuck wird.
Also, wo ist das Docker-Compose-File? Zeig ich mal her.
App.
Da ist es bestimmt drin.
API, API, Aggregator.
Docker-Compose.
Also.
Container Name
DB
Moment, die bilden das selbst
oder was, den Container?
Ja, machen sie.
Okay, das sieht
in der Tat jetzt recht
unspektakulär aus.
Postgres Entry Point
bla bla bla
host all
set server
ist das
ist das eine Liste mit
von welchen
Netzen man Zugriff
auf die Postgres Datenbank hat
also von allen hausen
ja hausbasierte authentifizierungs datei
hoffen wir mal dass das da alles stimmt
darf ich die überhaupt meditieren
Ja, okay, ich darf alles editieren.
So, dann haben wir API.
Ja gut, da muss ich wahrscheinlich nichts dran ändern.
API Aggregator.
Okay, überall gibt es eigene Docker-Files.
Naja, dann machen wir doch einfach mal Docker Compose minus...
Nee, Docker Compose ab und gucken, was passiert.
Er baut erstmal Docker-Images.
Ich hab halt den blöden Verdacht, dadurch, dass der selbst die Anwendungen baut und selbst die Container-Images, dass da auch irgendwelche Fehler drin sind.
Oh shit, was?
Connected to the database, ready to serve requests. No, server is not set.
Oder bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob der set ist?
oder nicht doch set ist.
Okay, also Connection Refused zur Postgres.
Init db
cannot be run as root.
Init db cannot be run as root.
Okay.
Also.
Vielleicht muss er doch das Docker-File anpassen.
Was wir schönes machen,
wir fixen kaputte Linux-Server.
das ist die aufgabe hier wir haben ein kaputtes docker compose file mit der web anwendung und
der postkurs datenbank aus irgendwelchen gründen startet der ganze kram nicht wir müssen jetzt
rausfinden woran es liegt und das fixen also wir haben schon mal probleme mit dem postgres container
postgres ql aber ich muss mal gucken ob er in das docker compose reingucken also database
XURP Aggregator.
Set Server.
Ah, nee, das ist der Benutzername.
So, Set.
Den gibt es überhaupt nicht, oder?
Chat.
Wer ist Set Server?
Ach, AddDB.
Das ist das Passwort. Bin ich blöd.
Alter, das ist das Passwort.
AddDB. Okay, hier, das da.
Das ist das Ding.
Container name db.
Build Postgres.
Also sprich, wir haben das Problem, dass init db läuft als root.
Das heißt, ich muss das mit einem anderen User machen.
Und darf das, also ich muss das als User Postgres machen.
Gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus.
Also sagen wir mal sudo.
Ich hoffe, Sudo ist installiert.
Oh nein, nicht wieder dieser komische Song.
Also ich hoffe mal, Sudo ist installiert.
Sudo minus U.
Postgres.
Und dann?
Minus C?
Chat, wie führt man so?
Muss ich mal kurz selbst mal ausprobieren.
Sudo minus U.
Sudo minus User Max.
Minus C.
Ne.
So schon mal nett
Einfach so
Äh
Okay
Dann kann man das wohl einfach
Einfach so ausführen
So
Ab
Dann schauen wir mal
Der müsste jetzt den Container neu bauen oder?
Warum hat er den Container nicht neu gebaut,
obwohl sich die Datei geändert hat?
Äh, wie war? Docker Compose.
Was gibt's denn da? Rebuild?
Build?
Jetzt hat das
rebuildet.
Okay.
Das sieht schon besser aus.
Also, User
Ach, Pseudo not found.
Fuck.
Okay, wir
exec'en uns mal da kurz.
Rein.
Docker exec'
minus
db.
Ist da eine Bash drin, irgendwas?
Also, der startet immer wieder neu. Das ist natürlich unpraktisch und auch einen ordentlichen...
Jetzt fliegen wir natürlich raus.
So, Sudo is not found.
Ähm.
Was haben wir denn?
haben wir su drauf
ok su haben wir drauf
immerhin
su ist drauf
also können wir dann quasi sagen
su
minus max
also su minus postgres
aber da ist es minus c
genau
irgendwo war es minus c
so aus kreis minus c diesen körper bild
kompost ab
Was?
Init db command not found
Ich weiß schon, warum das Database
from hell ist
Okay, Chat
Wir müssen das mal anders machen
Wir sleepen jetzt hier
für ganz lange Zeit
Und ich exec mich mal
in den Container rein und gucke mal ein bisschen da drin rum
gibt es nicht aber jetzt die best drauf ist ab update jedes darin auch das geht natürlich nicht
also
in etb user bin postgres in etb also wenn ich es minus postgres mache
ist auch kein bild ist ein schellbild
in.
Okay, das funzt.
Init DB
funzt nicht.
Die drei Tabs. Ja, wir haben
unsinnig. Es sind einfach zwei Tabs. Ich bin auf dem
gleichen Server einfach mehrfach
eingeloggt.
Hier unten bin ich im Container drin.
Okay.
Echo Path.
Wo ist denn dieses?
Hier, guck dir mal.
Das ist da ja im Path drin.
Naja gut, dann
können wir initdb da einfach von Hand reinschreiben.
Einfach, in Anführungszeichen.
Und dann gucken wir mal.
Dann machen wir jetzt hier so
initdb.
So, hier das Sleep.
Machen wir nur auf 5 wieder.
Ich mach mal nochmal ein auskommentiertes
Sleep
unten drunter.
Das brauchen wir bestimmt nochmal.
So.
Gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Das müssen wir uns auch noch drum kümmern.
Aber erstmal muss die Datenbank starten.
Sonst funktioniert es überhaupt nicht.
Pause Champ?
Macht der was?
Pausierungs Champ?
Ich glaube, der macht was.
Oder der hat was gemacht.
Ja, die B läuft noch.
Die DB läuft noch.
Gibt es alles nicht.
Okay, ich glaube, das haben wir gefixt.
Ach, ich habe noch nicht rebuildet.
Aber warum kackt es da nicht ab, wenn ich nicht rebuildet habe?
Ach so, weil ich noch das Sleep drin habe.
Kann man sowas hier sagen?
Rebuild?
Oder so, Build?
Ah, nice.
Dann führen wir das nämlich immer so aus.
Ah, guck mal, er macht was.
Ich muss das generell...
Sag mal, kann ich nicht einfach im Docker-Compose-File umstellen,
dass mein...
Nicht im Docker-Compose-File.
Umstellen in meinem Docker-File, dass der User-Root nicht Root, sondern Postgres sein soll?
Das wäre doch wahrscheinlich viel sinniger, oder?
als mein komisches Gebastel hier.
Also, dass ich einfach sage
Postgresql Dockerfile
und dann kann man
User Postgres oder so
sagen.
Irgendwie so.
User
Dockerfile. Weil ich mir da gar
nicht sicher bin, ob das nicht nur
zur Build Time
Set User
and Group ID.
Ah ja.
Nee.
For the man of the current stage.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Läuft das jetzt?
Läuft das dann als Postgres,
wenn ich das so mache?
Nee.
Ich glaube, das ist nichts in uns weg der Sache.
Oder wir probieren es mal.
Ja, einfach nur Build.
Bin ich mir jetzt gerade nicht sicher.
Okay, okay, es hat anscheinend schon mal funktioniert.
Es hat funktioniert.
Das heißt, wir können auch
diesen Kram hier wieder rausnehmen
Was ich hier gemacht habe
Und einfach wieder sagen
init db
Weil das sollte ja alles
eigentlich jetzt als User
auscress laufen
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
Ja
Okay
Ich würde sagen
Die Datenbank funktioniert
Das heißt als nächstes
Müssen wir jetzt schauen
Dass der
API-Cregator ein bisschen sleept
Oder sowas, bevor er startet
Also
api aggregator locker fall was macht das ding weil ich vertippe ich da immer so oft ich schreibe
immer so oft dicker feile also der sagt cmd not okay der führt es direkt aus dafür ist direkt aus
Können wir nicht sagen
Irgendwie in dem
Compose File
Ja doch
Ich kann ein Depends On machen
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob der Depends On auch
Dieses
Das checkt
Aber der hat auch schon Depends On API
Aber API dependet nicht
On DB
Ja, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob der das Sleep da drinnen checkt
Das ist halt das Ding.
Wenn nicht, muss man da irgendwie noch ein Sleep einbauen.
Ja, siehst du, das bringt nichts.
Aber mit API...
Okay, warte.
Dependent on DB.
Ja, guck, guck.
Wir müssen ein Sleep einbauen in die anderen Containern.
Kann man Docker Compose Sleep?
Geht das irgendwie?
Sleep?
Before Start?
Gibt es da irgendwie sowas?
Oh ja, Health Check ist eine sehr clevere Idee.
Hier, guck mal.
Guck mal.
Ah, ja, Health-Check.
Sehr gut. Chat, ihr seid
high IQ heute.
Aber kann ich auch einfach
einen Sleep reinmachen, oder?
Ich will ja nichts curlen.
Das ist ja das Ding. Ich will ja gar nichts curlen.
Ich will einfach nur einen Sleep.
Condition Service Healthy.
Aha.
Ah, der kann sich selbst Health checken.
Das heißt, ich muss den Health check...
Gucken wir mal, was hier noch andere...
Health Check Feature.
Wir könnten aber auch
Also es gibt zwei Varianten
Wir machen einen Health-Check
Oder wir gehen jetzt einfach hier rein
In das Docker-File
Aber der startet halt direkt die Anwendung
Das ist halt ein bisschen doof
PG ist ready
Das ist ja nice
Moment
P.G. ist ready.
Ah.
Excellent, Leute.
Excellent.
Hauptsache ein bisschen durchdrehen.
Das finde ich nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Docker compose.
So.
Das heißt, die DB braucht einen Health-Check.
Also diese, ganz ehrlich,
Dieser Clipboard Manager ist übelste Kacke.
Ich schiebe es mal auf Wayland wieder,
dass Wayland übelste Kacke ist.
Das ist einfach nicht drin, wenn ich das kopiere.
So, wenn ich jetzt so mache, geht es dann.
Nö, nö.
Juckt es einfach nicht.
Ist lange nicht im Clipboard Manager.
Also die DB braucht ein Health Check.
Set Paste.
Ups.
Set, Paste.
Zack.
Health Check.
X.
Also, wie war das?
PG is ready.
So, ja.
Retries 5, Timer 10, Intervall 30, Alter.
Intervall 10.
Okay.
So, und jetzt muss ich was sagen?
Depends on Condition Service Healthy.
Sehr schön.
Äh.
Äh, Chad, ist das gültiges Jammer?
Ist das gültiges Jammer?
Hoffen wir mal.
condition weiter einrücken näher
die pension must be a string okay
Ähm
Äh
Okay, wir machen es einfach so
Depends on API
Und API depends on
DB
So, hä
Okay, nice
Okay, jetzt ist es ready
Starten die anderen jetzt
Nice
Okay, wir haben wieder
Wir haben noch andere Probleme
Aber wir nähern uns
Wir nähern uns dem Problem, ja
Also wir haben schon einiges gefixt.
Moment.
Aber der trustet doch.
Der trustet doch alles.
Oder ist das falsche Syntax?
Das ist bestimmt falsche Syntax.
Wer zum Teufel
weiß denn diese Syntax hier?
Erklären.
Naja, das weiß ich.
So, Host gilt für diese Hilfe nicht für lokale Unix-Sockets.
Gilt für alle Datenbanken.
Gilt nur für den Benutzer Postgres.
Ja, Moment, den wollte ich doch eben auch benutzen.
Erlaubt Verbindung von jeder IPv4-Adresse, keine Passwortabfrage.
Joch.
Da müsste es doch eigentlich funktionieren, oder?
No Entry for Host.
Ach, User.
User API Aggregator
Benutzer Postgres
Ah
Okay
Dann
Also im Endeffekt das hier
Für
API Aggregator
Wie viel Zeit
hat man eigentlich noch
37 Minuten
Oh.
Chat, sag bloß, das funktioniert jetzt alles.
MonkaW.
Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt gleich der nächste Fehler.
Okay, next.
Also, das haben wir hinbekommen.
NGX-Server.
Moment, was ist denn der NGINX-Server jetzt?
API vielleicht?
Oder haben wir auf dem Host...
Ach, wir haben auf dem Host einen NGINX.
Oder?
Ja.
So.
Certificate not found.
Nein! Bitte!
Please keine Zertifikatssachen jetzt noch zusätzlich.
Nein!
Keine Zertifikatssachen!
Das kann ich jetzt nicht noch gebrauchen.
Zertifikat Zertge.
Aber
Wir
Köln mal hier
Localhost
Port 9000 oder sowas
Up and running
Bam
Das ist
Und kann ich den API-Cregator auch irgendwie
Ne
Ach stimmt
Da steht was
hier du hast recht du hast recht wie sie
konnte und wie soll okay also müssen wir noch in haus
also punkt local
Oh, das ist doch das Zertifikat.
Okay, was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Zertifikatsprobleme.
Zertifikat hat gesperrt.
Die wollen ernsthaft von mir, dass ich jetzt noch ein neues Zertifikat für diesen Krempel generiere.
Monk, ich hasse Zertifikatskram.
Nginx.
N-Uhr zurückstellen.
Ja, eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee.
Das Third-Bot wird da drauf nicht funktionieren.
Basic Settings.
sites enabled default
ah hier
nginx server name set server.local
Lass uns mal gucken, wann das expired ist.
Das war.
Ach, das ist das CA-Sort?
Was?
Moment.
Wir verwenden für die CA
das gleiche.
Okay.
Show OpenSSL Content off.
Das ist irgendwas.
OpenSSL no text.
Bla.
Okay.
Genau, das habe ich gesucht.
Also.
Internet
Wittgitz.
Hier.
Not before.
Not after.
Okay, Leute.
Ich habe keinen Bock,
ein neues Zertifikat zu machen.
Wisst ihr, was wir machen könnten?
Wenn da kein NTP oder sowas läuft.
Ähm.
Date.
Oder.
Ein CTL.
Oder wie ging das nochmal?
Hier.
Daytime CTL.
Set.
NTP ist da was?
Schau.
Oder wie?
Kein NTP.
No!
Geh weg!
Ich hab keinen Bock ein Zertifikat auszustellen.
Aber wir können.
Set time.
In welchem?
Ja.
10. März.
wie sette man damit heim
wo soll ich denn die sind ankommen wissen
ab perfekt
also
das ist der Teil
Dritter
Zehnter um 15.30 Uhr.
Perfekt.
Wie kann man NTP ausschalten?
Set.
NTP vielleicht?
Force.
Bam.
Curl.
Ha!
Eats.
Ausgetrickst.
Einfach die Uhrzeit zurückgestellt.
Ups.
Bam.
Wir haben es geschafft, Leute.
Easy, Clap.
Wir hatten noch 30 Minuten Zeit.
Oh, was denn?
Also, das hat mir jetzt echt den Rest gegeben noch.
Aber jetzt mal blöde Frage.
Was war denn da jetzt so große
Database-Migration?
Das InitDB quasi aus dem
File zu restoren, oder was?
Vielleicht soll...
Vielleicht... Wisst ihr was?
Ich schreib dem das auf Twitter.
Dass es bei Florence sinnvoll wäre,
das Datum zu checken.
Das schreib ich dem nachher auf...
Auf X.
Formerly known as Twitter.
Fünf Stunden Chat.
Meine Güte.
Jetzt reicht es mir aber echt.
Morgen früh.
9 Uhr oder so.
9.30 Uhr.
Mal gucken, vielleicht gehe ich vorher eine Runde rennen.
Mal schauen.
Bin ich wieder am Start.
Wöchentlicher Aufwachen-Stream.
Das war anstrengend heute.
Aber wisst ihr, was gut ist?
Was richtig nice ist?
Schaut mal.
Wir haben im Prinzip noch
Keine Ahnung, 40 Aufgaben oder so
Noch übrig
30, 40 Aufgaben oder so
Also damit
Ja oder, ja 30
Also damit kriegen wir auf jeden Fall noch zwei Streams gefüllt. Jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt direkt im Anschluss, ich muss da immer ein bisschen Pause dazwischen machen, weil es mir dann irgendwann auch ein bisschen zu viel wird im Kopf. Aber da haben wir noch richtig, richtig nice Content.
eine Sache, die ich ja ein bisschen doof finde,
ist, guck mal, es gibt hier
zwei Aufgaben,
die sind nur für Business-Accounts.
Meine Vermutung ist,
du sollst nicht
die im Vorfeld machen können,
weil die Leute bei der Bewerbung
für Bewerbungsgespräche benutzen.
Weil ansonsten hoffe ich
nicht, dass die irgendwann
anfangen und Szenarien wirklich im
großen Stil Business-Account-Only machen.
Ich meine, ich habe einen Premium-Account,
das kostet glaube ich 80 euro im jahr oder so hier so und so eine count habe ich bei direct
direct ssh access 88 dollar im jahr ich hab das ich hab das ich habe das abo schon wieder
gekündigt ich hab das jetzt nur einmal quasi raus gehauen dass wir die ganzen übungen machen können
Aber das wäre echt blöd, wenn noch mehr Business
Weil Business-Accounts sind halt richtig krass teuer
Guck mal
245 Euro im Monat
Aber wie gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, dass das Absicht ist
Dass diese zwei Szenarien Business-Only sind
Dass die im Vorfeld halt keiner kennt
falls man in einem interview prozess das halt mal machen soll
danach können wir probieren szenarien selbst zu bauen
ich habe mir schon bei ein paar sachen überlegt dem zu schreiben sind die bei
dir trotzdem freigeschaltet die die business in der nähe
Ne, guck, bam.
Geht nicht.
Only available to business users.
Übrigens, ihr braucht auch gar kein Paid Account, gell?
Jetzt nur mal so nebenbei.
Also falls sich das jetzt so angehört hat,
ihr könnt auch relativ viele Sachen machen,
kostenlos komplett.
Also ihr braucht gar nichts hier, ne?
Ihr könnt auch Free Account erstellen.
Da habt ihr Zugriff auf alle,
die halt nicht Pro oder Business dran stehen haben.
Also ihr könnt die hier alle machen.
Die hier, die hier, die hier, das hier, das.
Also ich würde mal sagen, ungefähr...
Naja.
So einen Drittel oder so, würde ich vielleicht mal sagen.
So einen Drittel könnt ihr mit einem kostenlosen Account machen.
Also das lohnt sich auch.
Also man lernt da richtig viel dabei.
Also wenn ihr ein bisschen Linux-Know-How aufbauen wollt, ist das eine super Übungsseite.
Ich meine, wenn man wirklich sagt, ey, ich will mich jetzt ein bisschen mit Linux beschäftigen.
Mein Standard-Tipp kennt ihr ja.
Installiert euch Linux auf Mini-PC oder in der VM.
Nicht auf dem Main-PC und nicht Dual-Boot.
Da ist die Hürde viel zu groß, irgendwas zu machen.
Kauft euch einen Mini-PC oder installiert euch eine VM.
Habe ich auch ganz lange hier im Stream verwendet, bevor ich mir den Mini-PC gekauft habe.
Hier, guckt.
Hatte ich ganz lange hier meine Linux-VM im Fullscreen.
Das war auch vollkommen ausreichend.
Das Einzige, was ihr damit halt nicht machen könnt, sind irgendwelche Sachen spielen unter Linux.
Mit einer VM.
Und jetzt 4K-Videos gucken geht halt auch, aber geht ganz schön auf die CPU.
Aber ansonsten hier, vor allem im Fullscreen auch vollkommen fein.
Ja, zack.
Das ist das, was ich die ganze Zeit früher benutzt habe.
Und da habt ihr unter Windows, habt ihr quasi hier,
ups, mal kurz was machen,
Da habt ihr quasi hier das Windows Zeug und hier habt ihr das Linux Zeug dann. Alles auf dem gleichen Rechner, unterschiedlicher Desktop. Oh, was hat Ascii Quarium gerade gehabt? Gleicher Desktop, also unterschiedlicher Desktop, gleicher PC. Und dann könnt ihr einfach Linux für tägliche Aufgaben verwenden.
und man lernt damit einfach viel mehr, als wenn man nur Tutorials guckt oder irgendwelche Sachen liest
oder sich vielleicht einen Raspberry Pi kauft und darauf ein bisschen was macht.
Wenn man das täglich benutzt für tägliche Aufgaben, stehst du vor so vielen Fragezeichen,
die du quasi erstmal lösen musst, dann lernst du richtig was.
Gerade Shell-Umgang und Basics ist wirklich top.
Linux einfach in der VM.
Vmware Workstation ist mittlerweile auch kostenlos.
Und
damit könnt ihr, ihr könnt auch VirtualBox
nehmen, geht genauso gut, ja.
Übrigens, eine Sache, die ich letztens gefunden
habe, die ich unbedingt mal ausprobieren wollte,
AppSendBox.
Das da.
Hier. Das, das, das wollte ich mal
ausprobieren.
Menübar?
Ne, nicht Menübar.
Bookmarks.
Tool.
Always show.
Nur auf dich.
hab. Ganz abgedrehtes
Zeug.
GPU passt
through unter Windows.
In der VM. Also das, was
vor allem bei Workstation, Virtual Box und so unter Windows
nicht können.
Ja, ist Overkill.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich habe auch keine PS5.
Ich werde mir dafür auch keine PS5 kaufen.
Und ich glaube auch nicht,
dass es so geil ist, wie man es im Kopf hat
heute noch.
Zumal ich gelesen habe, dass sie ziemliche Verbindungs- und Lobbyprobleme haben müssen.
Und das ist auch eine Sache, wo ich mir halt...
Es geht auch auf der PS4.
Ich habe nur eine PS4.
Eine PS4 quasi Einstiegs-PS4.
Die Release-PS4 habe ich nur.
Ganz wahrscheinlich.
Kannst du wahrscheinlich vollknicken.
Ich glaube halt auch, dass sie das 0 supporten werden irgendwie.
Also alle Probleme und Sachen, die es jetzt gibt, werden für immer bestehen bleiben.
Das ist einfach nur für die Cash Crap.
Nostalgie Cash Crap.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das sehen werden.
Das ist meine Vermutung.
Das heißt nicht, dass sie das nicht machen werden,
hundertprozentig, aber ich gehe stark
davon aus, dass sie es nicht machen werden.
Moin.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendwas passiert.
Irgendwas sich
rühren wird.
Das wird einfach nur Low-Effort-Cash-Crab sein.
Ist meine
Vermutung, vielleicht lege ich auch falsch.
Ja gut,
das stimmt auch noch.
Ne, würde ich nicht machen.
Ich finde es übrigens auch dumm, dass es die nicht für den PC gibt, die Released-Dinger.
Aber auf dem PC werden die Dinger wahrscheinlich nach einem Tag so krass cheater verseucht, dass keiner spielen könnte.
Das liegt jetzt immer nicht am PC, sondern weil die halt unfähig sind zu programmieren.
Und die Sachen ja kleinzeitmäßig teilweise laufen bei Black Ops 1.
Linux-ISOs würde ich da auch bevorzugen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man meine PS4 crappen könnte.
Vielleicht.
weil die ist das ist eine release ps4 aber ich habe darauf firmware update gemacht da geht es
bestimmt nicht mehr oder ich habe für update gemacht ich hatte ich hatte probleme mit dvd
ist da habe ich mal firmware update gemacht er nicht aber ich habe eine release switch
kann ich kann ich die release switch kann man die kann man die irgendwie hacker mannen
Ja, Eats.
Also den werde ich nicht machen, weil ich überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck dafür habe.
Aber wäre vielleicht mal was für ein Stream.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, wie akzeptiert das auf Twitch ist,
Custom-Firmware auf Konsolen zu flashen.
Streng genommen ist das ja nicht illegal.
Ich kann mit meiner Hardware machen, was ich will.
Ich darf keinen Kopierschutz umgehen bei Spielen, ja.
Aber ich kann mit meiner Hardware machen, was ich will.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Wenn ich das halt öffentlich zeige und man dann argumentieren könnte,
das ist eine Anleitung,
dann weiß ich wieder nicht, wie das rechtlich ist.
Deswegen zeige ich das wahrscheinlich besser mal nicht.
Aber was ich mal unbedingt noch rausprobieren will,
das muss ich mir auftreiben.
Das will ich unbedingt machen.
Ich will meine alten Unify Access Points flashen mit OpenWrt.
Und gar nicht, weil ich die unbedingt verwenden will, sondern weil mich interessiert, wie es geht.
Und das wird richtig abenteuerlich, sag ich euch hier.
UAP Pro
OpenWrt.
Das wird richtig abenteuerlich.
Denn man muss da,
passt mal auf,
man muss da,
nee, das ist,
ja,
man muss da irgendwelche Sachen dran löten,
dass das funktioniert.
Das ist aber übrigens nicht der Richtige.
Der UAP Pro,
Oh, den meine ich.
Oder wird er gar nicht unterstützt?
Bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ich bilde mir einen. Das ging mal.
Haben die den vielleicht rausgenommen?
Naja.
Das wird auch wieder richtig krass gefrickelt.
Ja doch, die haben eine Möglichkeit, was zu sehen.
Bei mir im Stream.
Es ging ja nicht darum, ob ich es machen würde, privat,
sondern ob ich es zeigen würde im Stream.
Das ist ja das Ding.
So, dann mach ich mal den PC aus hier.
Zack, Power auf.
Bäm.
Machen wir auch zu.
Zack.
So.
Hätke.
Schön, dass ihr so zahlreich erschienen seid heute.
War ein sehr nicer Stream.
Fünf Stunden, sieben Minuten.
Hätte ich mal vor drei Tagen gemacht, da hätte ich noch
mein
Ukraine und Seagate Sellout machen können.
Aber ich habe ja lange genug
geschrieben und genug Sellout gemacht.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Und wir sehen uns.
Ich räume das
nachher alles auf.
Wir sehen uns morgen früh.
Bis dann, macht's gut, CU.